yeah so um yeah thanks for inviting me
to speak to you uh I'm Dan McQuillen I'm
a lecturer in creative and social
Computing at Goldsmith University of
London and I also recently wrote a book
called resisting AI an anti-fascist
approach to artificial intelligence
and what's the high level thesis of the
book
very much that if we don't pay attention
I AI will lead to an increasing
Amplified series of harms but that there
are alternatives you know I originally
set out to write a book called AI for
the people because I want to promote the
idea of Technology adding social value
and making Better Lives possible but I
ended up calling it resisting AI because
the kind of AI we have I think needs to
be resisted and we need something
radically different wonderful I should
get a shot at the book
okay so that's the video
that's a great way to start a podcast
isn't it
okay well um ladies and gentlemen
esteemed colleagues and friends it's
with great pleasure and profound
anticipation that I introduce you to a
remarkable individual a Visionary and a
Trailblazer in the realm of digital
culture social Innovation and data
science Dan McQuillen
a man who definitely traverses the
Realms of experimental particle physics
digital sociology and creative Computing
Dan embodies the essence of intellectual
curiosity interdisciplinary exploration
and social impact
Dan said on an interview that he has a
brother with Down syndrome and he's seen
at first hand what it's like to be
marginalized
in this ever evolving digital age where
data is King and algorithms shape Our
Lives Dan Champions the critical
principles of algorithmic accountability
data-driven equity and ethical
technology
through his work he illuminates the
importance of understanding the complex
interplay between technology and society
and the necessity to balance the
potential benefits with the ethical
considerations of emerging Technologies
as an academic at goldsmiths University
of London Dan has inspired countless
students and colleagues alike through
his teaching he's fostered a new
generation of thinkers who can challenge
convention and strive to make a
meaningful difference in the world
a passionate advocate for
interdisciplinary collaboration Dan
recognizes that the most pressing
challenges of our time demand the
collective wisdom of diverse
perspectives and areas of expertise
Now with an illustrious career spanning
roles at esteemed organizations like
Amnesty International and the social
Innovation Camp Dan has demonstrated the
transformative power of digital tools
and data science in addressing some of
the world's most pressing issues his
work serves as a testament to the
potential of technology to empower
uplift and ultimately to bring about
positive change so today we are
privileged to engage in a
thought-provoking conversation with Dan
as we navigate the intricacies of
digital culture social Innovation and
the ethical implications of artificial
intelligence we'll explore the Myriad
challenges and opportunities that lie at
the intersection of technology and
society and embark on a journey to
better understand the profound impact of
our digital world so Dan welcome to mlst
thanks very much for having me amazing
um give us a little bit of a background
or for myself yeah I mean how did it
because you started doing a PhD in
experimental particle physics that's
right yeah I even finished a PhD so yeah
um yeah but then I uh yeah so that's
that was um
where I started but actually I got a
little bit disillusioned with it over
the time that I was doing it and uh
immediately after that I worked with
people with learning disabilities and
people with mental health problems and
then partly because I was the only one
around in the organizations I was in
that had anything to do with tech I
strifted into the idea of Community
Technology and then you know the idea
that emerging Technologies of various
kinds could actually you know enhance
and amplify the kind of social goals
that people were working towards and
spent quite a lot of time in that area
worked for amnesty for a while trying to
boost the idea of digital human rights
essentially
and have worked for the NHS I've yeah
I've worked in a number of different
organizations
also social Innovation Camp was was
something that I started with a few
friends and colleagues to try to move
into a space that where nobody was
really doing that kind of thing at the
time internationally as well so so with
social Innovation Camp I went to some
amazing places like Kazakhstan Georgia
and Sarajevo to do these Innovation
camps just really trying to trigger
people's social imaginations through the
possibilities of the tech
and after one means or another I drifted
back into Academia which is where I am
now
fantastic well um
why don't we talk a little bit because
you've just written this very
interesting book called resisting AI
and um
maybe you could just trace a little bit
of a path to how you wrote this book and
you know what what are the core
arguments in the book
sure
um well as you could probably tell from
the bio I've always had a bit of a foot
in both camps in the sense that I am
interested in well science and
technology and but it's also always been
important to me
you know what values those things are
serving and what effects they're
bringing about in the world
so working in a Computing Department as
I do and I suppose I was relatively
early Observer through through my
practice through what colleagues are
doing of
the the kind of resurgence of data
science and then
perhaps we could call it the revolution
of recent AI of deep learning and so
forth so in my mind that immediately
provoked questions of what it was going
to do in the world and I wrote various
things about that touching on various
areas as as you know mental health or
particular social impacts and I was
talking about at one point when when
um Bristol University press said why
don't you write a book
and I did with the original aim of
um in some way kind of recapitulating
what I'd done before
of saying okay here's an emerging
technological
field you know in what ways could it be
bought to do good in a way so the
original working title was something
like AI for good or AI for the people
and but actually as I
worked through what AI actually does
operationally concretely computationally
and then also at the same time
simultaneously observing
the ways people are tending to use it in
the world and really trying to draw the
connections between those things the
bring out the resonances between these
very specific
computational operations and the kind of
um
relationships they were
entangled with in the outside world the
institutional effects and the social
impacts
I ended up writing a book called
resisting AI so resisting AI is a bit
hard to sort of um sum up briefly but it
would start out by trying to demystify
what AI is actually at the moment the
thing we think about is AI very
contested term of course
um and then it moves sort of
progressively through
um a series of
increasing levels of likely harm
and to a point where you know I use this
term which
is banded about a bit I suppose an
Academia called necropolitics which we
could talk about so I'm basically going
fairly dark on AI
but that then that's maybe halfway or
possibly two-thirds of the way through
the book I try to ask what else could be
done about it so I do try to
to
um fulfill that mission in a way by
saying where could we go
you know as a response to this
um
in ways that would
be broadly social socially beneficial
and I try to be specific about that so
it's a bit of an arc
we'll talk a little bit about the
language later that um necropolitics
casts real Etc why don't we start with
necropolitics okay well so necropolitics
is an idea by a writer a theorist called
akilene bembe who's um based in Africa
and he was really talking about the
post-colonial experiences in Africa
um particularly of you know so-called
post-colonial regimes this idea that
colonialism had somehow gone away and
that um I guess people's experiences in
these different countries in Africa was
therefore uh somehow radically
transformed from what it had been and
was also largely under the you know
control or or direction of people in
those places both of which you kind of
like radically disputed by
you know pointing out that the
ruthlessness of
um relations and the experiences that
people are subjected to were essentially
um you know as brutal as they had been
and that in fact we're not really
separate from what they had been under
colonialism and he called it
necropolitics I think because you know
that the brutality is is to the point of
um quite Stark divisions between who
gets what they need in order to survive
and thrive and who is really
um either allowed to die or um you know
encourage shoved firmly in that
direction
and I use necropolitics because I think
it's a good
way of encapsulating the overall effects
of systems that might describe
themselves in different ways they might
talk about
their missions under various mission
statements various sets of values but
viewing viewing their effects as a whole
um
to me you know it seemed to be
quite divisive and particularly in our
times
uh one side of that not start not neat
division but one side of that
division is
people whose life experiences are so
sort of reduced or immiserated that they
are much more likely to have both short
and quite unfulfilling lives and there's
another side of that divide so I think
um it's a term I can use across
um technical developments but also as
they relate to institutional
uh impacts or state level action I mean
I wrote quite a lot of the book during
covert so I think you can probably see
where that might influence some of the
interpretations or some of the readings
of
what are the underlying Dynamics here
and
more importantly what's their what's
their Direction what's their
directionality so that's and
necropolitics really just means it's not
about
um
going around killing people but it is
about the kind of thing that
came to the fore through covid let's say
in this country where
um people had to ask why is it that
certain parts of our population in a
very wealthy country are so much more
um vulnerable to
fatal Health impacts are or long-term
health effects how why is it that some
people let's say the population of East
London for example are so much more
vulnerable than others is it really some
identified genetic effect or is it
really accumulative
um very long lasting transgenerational
result of
fairly obvious things of growing up in
poor housing with poor nutrition
poor life chances so
um
covid Was Made It by compressing the
time axis I think in some way covid made
it very obvious that these effects
underlay to me and that was my
understanding of it that cover made a
really clear those Dynamics underly a
lot of our experiences so necropolitics
is a useful term for me to talk about
these kind of systemic effects you were
speaking to their that when Sam outman
open AI he says that he's doing AI for
good it's going to be a good thing and
then you can disentangle the intention
from the consequence and there were
these system you know systematic um
systemic forces that you were just
speaking to and and of course they are
um incentivized to present things in a
very positive way it's PR it's marketing
so um it might be quite an interesting
time as well just to bring in
a very interesting question from Nick on
on our Discord because when I read
Chomsky many years ago he spoke about I
think he called it neo-imperialism
which is this idea that it's not like
the old days where we would go with our
guns and take take people over
um it's now markets so we will install
markets in their country and and we
spread the American culture he called it
the kind of hegemonic neo-imperialism
and isn't it interesting to think of
machine learning and large language
models as being a second order of
globalization and colonialization so um
yeah Nick said on our Discord Community
simultaneously spurring balkanization uh
we already see consolidation of early
leads founded on Western primary English
online data so the implication is join
or be left behind this collapses our
cultural space and prompts competitive
digging in from global global players
outside to the Joiner sphere so would
you think that this this third order of
technology is is the new you know
colonialization
uh yeah I mean I think the short answer
would probably be yes but I think it's
also um
it that would be a kind of
understanding or kind of moment of
realization I think of something that
was always already there that that
situation hasn't changed you know the
the alarm and and and sort of
um vulnerability that a lot of people
are now experiencing I think through
large language models
let's say in Academia just to pick a
sort of example close to home where
people are suddenly thinking
well maybe I'm disposable you know maybe
my job's at risk and if my job's at risk
what other aspects of my life are going
to Tumble in a domino like way well
precarity vulnerability
of that kind is
you know is most people in the world's
current experience
and has been I don't know certainly
since the days of
Empire and colonization so it's not
really that stuff ever went away
um but but on the other hand it's
important to think about yeah what are
these
forms of computation bringing to that
and in what ways are they diverting from
it as well I mean just to Circle back to
Sam Altman uh I think
some of some of it is very crude you
know it's when you're talking about
Investments of billions of dollars you
know that overrides many many things and
but I think it's useful as well from
what you said that that idea of the the
good you know it's it's good to remember
that there isn't really any such thing
as the good you know there are many many
different kinds of good
and so really talking about say
technology for good or large language
models for good is
by itself a meaningless statement and
possibly one that's used to conceal
other things in their case I would say
it in the sort of their case in the idea
of open AI particularly by their own
you know by the they as they State this
themselves and quite a few of the other
significant players in the AI space as
we know it at the moment because of
their commitments to ideas like AGI
artificial general intelligence
um
their idea of good is very skewed
towards
um an already defined worldview in which
the emergence of agis is inevitable and
the most significant historical thing
that's probably ever happened and so
generously you know if we're looking
Beyond Market valuation we'd say their
idea of good is very steered by that and
and I think there's a growing awareness
that
um and you know under the rubrics of
people understanding what does uh let's
say long-termism stand for Effective
altruism and I know you've covered some
of these things you know on the channel
already people's growing awareness that
these visions of the future are well
they're very particular visions
and I would say they also fall into that
categorization pretty neatly as well you
know they're there
hyper Colonial Visions in
my estimation so yeah there's a lot of
it a lot of coloniality in there could I
press you on that a tiny bit so I also
spoke with um uh Professor Michael Levin
is a famous biologist a few weeks ago
and and he was speaking about
transhumanism and again this is my
naivety because I didn't think it was a
loaded term and it's a transhumanism You
could argue as being very similar to
those other things you just spoke about
um like effective altruism and so on and
you know the problem is maybe there's a
naivety here because when when people
speak about things like a quality of
opportunity and the the opportunity to
use this clever AI to give yourself an
opportunity to be the best version of
yourself or to in transhumanist say to
use AI to fill in missing capabilities
or whatever and
on the other side of the coin it's been
linked to things like Eugenics so could
you could you explain the dichotomy
there
um yeah I mean I'm not uh I certainly
don't subscribe to the transcuminous
viewers you could probably tell yes
um
I would say the idea of enhanced
intelligence
which
AGI is a an instantiation of and I think
transhumanism as well kind of pivots on
um
you know
is a very narrow view of intelligence
for one thing
but what it also does is assert by
definition
uh more or less linear idea of
intelligence that there's greater
intelligence and lesser intelligence
rather than just say different
intelligences
and
of course there are many layers of that
it's this idea of intelligence is
entirely based on
sort of cognitive rationality as well
which
a lot of other people would say is a
very restricted porthole on the world
um very disembodied you know it's these
things are very they're the kind of
distillations of
some of the problems that other people
would call Enlightenment thinking you
know or or
um humanism actually so transhumanism is
a kind of a
amped up version of humanism but what
those definitely do in my estimation is
and they can't come without their own
binary if there's
enhanced intelligence there's reduced
intelligence if there's higher
intelligence there's lower intelligence
and there's absolutely a value
commitment towards the higher
intelligence you know yes you might say
there's an aspiration towards
um
spreading this idea of higher
intelligence but that actually is
exactly what Eugenics was Eugenics
wasn't
primarily death camps Eugenics was
and I don't know why I'm saying was
because it's everywhere still but
Eugenics is
fundamentally this idea of
um optimizing so we can see where the
connection to machine learning might
come in of optimizing
population levels of intelligence
narrowly defined
and with eugenics
comes that double move wanting to
enhance and sort of wanting to
remove or perhaps eliminate in some
sense the the other they're reduced
and the lesser the unhelpful the
unproductive the you know uncreative I
mean however it is defined in a
particular way so that that's what
Eugenics isn't
having
worked into the idea of eugenics through
exploring
what AI as we currently know is I I
don't know at the moment I'm
I just can't stop seeing it it's popping
up everywhere it is but particularly in
the narratives around
well actually in the narratives around
chat GPT
or the or large language models
um
Gary Marcus posted a
substack newsletter a couple of weeks
ago with some chilling quotes from
Jeffrey Hinton you know where he's
comparing he's he's asserting
the innate intelligence of a large
language model by comparing making a
direct comparison to something that an
adult with a learning disability would
say
and I know what he's trying to say I
don't agree with it anyway because I
don't think lunch language models have a
thing that we would call intelligence in
them
but I also think because of this
question you've asked me about the
axis of eugenics that's already
so problematic as a way of thinking
about things and should be challenged
immediately otherwise this stuff will
just tumble forward
yeah there's so many things to pick up
on there I mean intelligence is
particularly complicated because there's
the Spearman approach of you know having
um a latent factor or there's the
gardener approach of thinking as a
collection of diverse intelligences
um but even with something like
disability I mean I'm I'm building a
startup company helping people you know
with deaf people read conversations when
they can't hear and and you could argue
that that's a form of transhumanism
because I I guess the the points that
you're making is that all of these
things lead to increased stratification
of society or increased inequality
because some folks will have the
opportunity and other folks won't and
you get these feedback loops where right
things are reinforced and reinforced in
the stratification is kind of solidified
yeah so that that's that's the problem
sure I mean
I have a commitment to the idea that
the kind of thing you were describing is
still possible you know that we can
mobilize whatever tools to hand to
make everyone's experience of society
better and to open that up to people I
mean deaf people I think historically
themselves would have been you know I
mean still are in a lot of ways but
would have been radically marginalized
and also regarded as of lesser
intelligence simply because they were
deaf in previous years so you know it's
it's
um but but I guess the point I'm making
there though is is you you reject the
idea that there's a scale of
intelligence and more is better and
similarly you could make the disability
argument that
um
you know more isn't necessarily better
maybe it's bad to say that having a
disability is is is a problem and that
needs to be solved
I think
my feeling about disability as such is
that
it's much more useful to think about it
in terms of what blocks are we putting
in people's ways already yeah
um you know you you could say well we're
you know we're helping people into
social participation fine but actually
you could equally look around and say
well actually why were we blocking
people from social participation in the
first place because we weren't taking
their differences into account I think
differences are really
pivotal Concept in all of this you know
the the valuing of difference
um and the seeing of differences kind of
difference has constitute constitutive
fundamentally constituting as
fundamentally valuable
um
so in that sense I think
there's also uh in some things that are
intended to be for good
could also have a possibility of sort of
trying to homogenize difference back
into the world that we're already all
used to and accepting of rather than
perhaps challenging our own
uh
ways of going about the world or the
world the worldings that we make the
world that we live in that that seems to
have many reasons why it should be
questioned and maybe starting from other
people's experiences exactly the way to
question it right rather than just
try to yank them up and make them as
much like us as possible
indeed okay
one other thing just but just before we
get on to your chat GPT argument is um I
spoke with Luciano floridi
um at Oxford he's invented this
philosophy of information
and um he used this wonderful term
called reontologizing which is to say
you know changing our existence so he
said that once once digital immigrants
like us are replaced by digital natives
like our children the immigration will
become complete and future Generations
will increasingly feel deprived excluded
handicapped or poor whenever they are
disconnected from the infosphere like
fish out of water he's got this idea
that
um the infosphere and information is
almost the primary lens to understand
what goes on in the world right um so he
said that information and communication
Technologies are re-ontologizing which
is an even more extreme form of
re-engineering us and our society which
is to say our intrinsic nature is being
transformed he said that we're modifying
our everyday perspective on the ultimate
nature of reality our metaphysics from a
material one like it used to be in the
olden days and what you know where
physical objects and processes play a
key role to an informational one and
eroding our autonomy and agency as a
result so what do you think about that
information View
well there's a lot in there I mean I
think the real re-ontologizing thing is
great I mean I do really think that um
one it's it's incredibly
important to when understanding the
impacts of the kind of things that we've
got a common interest in Ai and
um machine learning to understand that
impacts aren't
um
simply exterior categorizations you know
that the the effects of Technology
always always have shaped our own
understandings of ourselves and our own
understandings of the world so again you
know the whole metaphysics thing I'm
completely down with that
um you know and and really hunting
myself for and possible possible sort of
footholds it's a bit like going to a
climbing wall you know you're looking
for for ways to to navigate when
um I think can be a positive thing the
odd certainty is a clearly
um insufficient and I'd agree with that
bit as well I mean the the information
stuff
it doesn't do it for me you know I'm I'm
a materialist but but I'm a kind of um
probably I'm really a new materialist
which is uh
well it's a broad field of thoughts and
it's very influenced by feminism it's
very influenced by science and
technology studies it's very influenced
by this idea that uh realities are
plural but but not infinitely you know
that
um it's not uh
trying to
um certain not relativism but it's also
not trying to abstract from the material
experience or the embodied experience is
very much trying to sort of embrace
those and situated within them but
understanding that uh perhaps just in
every day in every way we're constantly
reproducing
a reality or produce reproducing
realities with each other so I think I'm
I'm I'm I just I I understand I think
something of the information approach I
think it's actually funny enough quite
influenced by physics
and uh it's not something that uh well
let's say I'm particularly interested in
I mean I I have my own Dodges for these
things you know because we have talked a
bit about intelligence and I talk about
it in in the book as well
you know in terms of the entanglement
with Eugenics but actually I'm not that
interested in intelligence per se
artificial or otherwise I'm not that's
not my primary driver what I care about
is
why we don't care more about what's
happening to other people in society or
perhaps to the planet as well that seems
you know increasingly pretty important
and what I'm interested in is the
effects
one way or the other that new
Technologies and Technical Arrangements
of ordering
our lives and Society what effects they
have on those things that was my
the path I tried to pursue through the
book I'm not engaging in a in a
particularly in a debate about
the nature of intelligence or whether
machines are I don't care actually what
I'm interested in is
our shared experience
on this particular planet
okay well I mean before we started
recording you said something very
interesting which is that
um I mean you're a materialist and there
are certain laws in the physical world
that we live in and then we have all of
these kind of I think you would still
use the word emergent realities that can
possibly
um derive from those underlying rules
but it's still something which to a
certain extent we have the power to
create so rather than discovering one
true reality given the possible
traversal space we we have some
flexibility there to choose the kind of
reality that we want
yeah absolutely I think that's nicely
put I mean I do think there are
constraints I mean I'm you know I
haven't
uh I wouldn't describe myself as a
physicist uh anymore if I ever was one
but I you know I have a lot of
um
I think science is incredibly important
in as much as it helps us to understand
um particular range of those constraints
physical
uh Medical
you know uh
that that's important I think it's
problematic when that simply becomes
elevated to the highest truth or perhaps
the only form of Truth finding or the
only form of world making because I
agree with you
you know there are
um
always at every moment uh the making of
Worlds is going on and the exploring of
the possibilities in that and
particularly the exploring of
possibilities which actually might uh
reduce suffering increase well-being
spread
plural
possibilities for what it is to be alive
and what what identities could be these
are
potentially very open
and in actual fact
the main problem there is that there are
various Dynamics and forces and
interests constantly working to shore up
the the sort of flood Banks to prevent
those different possibilities from
emerging they are already there they're
already uh more than latent they're sort
of working away but there's a constant
effort and to shovel us into a narrow
range of identities to restrict
uh
the distribution of goods or the um uh
spread of social status whatever it is
in very narrow limited ways that clearly
serve
narrow interests so
um life is a very experimental business
you know we don't understand it and
that's fine because we're immersed in it
I mean that's the other way of
understanding things you know uh life is
a very participatory the idea that we
could stand outside of things come to
some single final understanding of it
that allowed us to uh deduce or infer
what it's going to what's going to
happen next is
um
well I'd say it's delusional but it's
also like dangerously delusional
I just wanted to pick about a couple
things I mean first of all I suppose you
would say as Chomsky did that it's
mostly because of the profit motive
markets private Enterprise and so on
that produces some of these toxic
behaviors and and what we need is it's a
stronger social project but I also
wanted you to comment on the difference
between reality as you said and meaning
because some folks for example um I mean
even Jordan Peterson he's a narrativist
and he thinks that we use stories to
construct meaning about the world and I
just wondered when you when you talk
about this kind of social reality do you
mean meaning or do you mean reality
well I think
um
one of the important navigational tools
to have for all of us I think is an
understanding of
um
how to move with both meaning and
material and they are labels that we put
on our experiences our physical
experiences our emotional experiences uh
um experiences of our imagination those
are labels that we put on things and one
constant with that kind of labeling is
it almost always has an a priority
division between those things and I
think that's kind of
um pragmatic you know I
do experience myself as having internal
experience and I imagine for myself that
you have that and all the evidence to me
suggests that and with everybody else as
well and yet there are and we have
shared material realities this table
isn't going anywhere
um
but I also think is that in itself is
the interesting point you know at what
points in our understandings at what
points in our agreements about shared
reality
do those divisions get made
and what are what are the flexibilities
in them I think that's undetermined
because it's quite interesting is um uh
Nick on our Discord Community he was
flicking through your paper data
Sciences machinic neoplatonism which I
think is quite cool to bring in here but
you you said in that paper that while
machine learning and data science May
sometimes be criticized for their
reductionist approach we'll talk about
that to understand complex phenomena
it's often that the true goal of these
fields is often to identify deeper
patterns and relationships with
enlarging complex data sets in this
sense there's a parallel with the
neoplatonic emphasis on seeking a deeper
understanding of reality and the
underlying principles that govern it in
contrast the neoplatonic approach
emphasizes contemplation and
introspection let's put an anchor on
that as a means of gaining insight into
the underlying principles that govern
reality and whilst this approach may be
less immediately applicable to the task
of undercovering um patterns within
complex data sets that may offer a
different kind of insight and
perspective on the nature of reality and
our place in it now um one thing we'll
explore a little bit is is the
difference between humans and machines
because the con
that's Google home huh yeah and Google
wants to get involved in the interview
did you say a trigger word or something
I understand this the AI doesn't work AI
doesn't work
um but yeah we when we when we um use
language it's quite often it's
anthropomorphic so contemplation
introspection because presumably you
would think
Transformers models for example these
language models they're not doing
introspection right but maybe they are
right they they've got multiple levels
of information passing back and back and
back and is is it really so different
well people have a different take on
that you know
as as I was kind of alluding to in a way
you know there are different
understandings of cognition thought
consciousness
which I think is vital I mean ask
because it does
serve as a very handy indicator towards
some of the limitations of sort of
positive scientific knowledge that there
isn't really any
half convincing uh
formulation of Consciousness within that
particular framework at the moment now
those ideas about thoughts might be very
valid those thoughts about thought might
be very valid
um it's not
particularly my concern
you know my concern is not to understand
thinking it's to think about why the
things in the world are happening the
way they are what
um
these machines will intensify and how
that could be done differently
um I I don't I do think that um
there's some really good
efforts around things like well
particularly around things like
inactivism actually to to explore the
different possibilities of my
understanding of that like really
crudely would be you know trying to
bring together let's say a scientific
Viewpoint and a phenomenological one and
that seems like really valuable sort of
um seem to try to mine but uh that's a
very worthy and necessary thing and
I think it's important to have a
non-restrictive idea about the division
between meaning and material
but for my concern it's not necessary to
have come to a conclusion on that
pathway before recognizing that some of
the things we're doing are just really
very clearly harmful
two other beings in whatever way you
consider them to have an existence and
um
well yeah interesting
um I'm I'm a fan of an activism as well
although I must say from this
conversation I mean just for folks in
the audience an activism is is a it's a
really a relatively recent idea in
cognitive science in the last 20 years
where you decompose cognition focusing
on actions through affordances and
affordances is basically just the the
interface between the inside and the
outside other things so the affordances
I can pick up this can of Coke I can act
and then you can take trajectories of
actions through some space but the the
problem with the inactivist approach in
in my opinion because it also uses the
world as its own best representation so
it's a step away from
representationalism and it's actually
um an acknowledgment that we can't model
subjective experience so it's almost
saying let's focus on what's outside the
system rather than the internal mental
States and and that that's basically
behaviorism 2.0
yeah I mean you know like it's not I'm
not wanting to sort of Clump Trump over
people's feet who have very well
immersed in that area my understanding
would be there are different ways of
enacting in activism yes
um the the very variants you describe
which I'd say are the more predominant
ones because they fit more closely and
easily with science
um do have exactly have that kind of
flattening effect I don't think they're
the only ones I think the the the the
the more
um radically phenologically oriented
ones you know because they they
themselves become marginal within an
activism but
it's so it's not these these issues
aren't recognized and I meant to say by
the way it's like uh just to pick up on
the Jordan Peterson thing yes you know
maybe
you know you bring me here you sit me
down and you compare me to Jordan piece
and I don't know I mean this could be my
point to storm out of the interview
um
then actually was the idea of uh you
talked about second order or even third
order right at the beginning I think
Donna haraway has a really uh valuable
little contribution a little bit in the
sense of it's a short contribution
within one of her texts where she says
you know it's important the stories that
we tell stories with it's important that
the thoughts that we think Thoughts with
she's trying to to again to make that
sort of second order move and I would
say
Someone Like Jordan Peterson is drawing
on a very particular form of storifying
things I mean I'm not really interested
in exploring his ideas of meaning versus
materiality just to say the stories that
he's drawing on themselves are have very
particular social payloads and also have
very particular historical resonances
and they are not the only stories that
could be drawn from and and sort of um
uh perhaps a demonstrator of the danger
of uh restricting
you know your ideas of storifying
reality to certain particular narrow
Mythic
Frameworks but yes we don't want to go
on down at that rabbit hole maybe well
maybe just another 30 seconds down the
rabbit hole because I I recently watched
a video on philosophy tube about it and
I'm trying to remember the details but
apparently he his um brand of philosophy
is phenomenology so it's how you feel
this narrative isn't thing influencing
from structuralism and uh and I think um
Abigail Thorne on on philosophy to you
know she said well it's not bad he just
stopped reading at 1950 or something and
he should have just kept reading because
maybe you could just quickly contrast
that to some of the ideas I think which
have influenced you in in post-modernism
and post-structuralism
but but also I think and and you know
you can you can
poke me as much as you like about this
because I don't think you you can
completely distinguish the ideas from
the person it's not that ideas are
entirely reducible to biography as I'm
saying oh he only thinks that because of
XYZ or
um Sam Altman is only saying these
things because
um his company is raking in loads of
money from it it's not reducible in that
way but it is also a bit like this
material meaning thing it's not
separable and I think you can it doesn't
take too much
for me to be able to step back from
someone like Peterson and the many many
others there are at the moment and
that's part of the problem there are
many many others right in that ilk and
see that
with your other ear that this is
absolutely a defense of Right male
privilege and
um you know and white supremacy that's
how it's been deployed and if that is
perhaps
um valid philosophical framework well
then that valid philosophical framework
needs some other philosophical
Frameworks because by itself it has a
clear social payload and you know I
adopt ideas let's say post-structuralist
or whatever they are also not
somehow come from the realm of pure
thought I mean they were born from
people who experienced the events of
1968 and sought to understand all
aspects of those events sought to
understand the essentially
insurrectionary energies and the
um wonderful new possibilities that
people seem to perceive but also the way
those events seem to sabotage themselves
and seem to in some ways end up
maybe even strengthening the thing they
were fighting against yes so um you know
uh
we had a chat earlier on before we
started recording about you know
perhaps you might call it positionality
or what I call it standpoint or situated
knowledge is that you know we are we are
all approaching the our understandings
of the world
from a certain place I am here right now
in this embodied being and I do find it
hugely valuable to learn from other
thinkers and their thoughts about the
world but at the end of the day my
position will be filtered through my
life experiences my aspirations and so
with these other thinkers to ignore that
and to say well um okay someone like
Jordan Peterson has a you know very
thoughtful and valid philosophy so it
must be okay that the world is arranged
this way I totally dispute
yes it's so interesting because we were
speaking about this concept of
relationalism and also relativism before
before we started um recording and
fluidi said the same thing he said that
um even if you're a philosopher there
needs to be a purpose there's a question
there's an answer there's a purpose you
need to understand everything in in
relation but then there's the question
of in what relation right because
um I think Peterson even wrote a book
called maps of meaning where presumably
he spoke about all of this stuff and
that's a relational framework to because
it's almost like in order to know or
understand something there needs to be a
relational framework but which is the
correct relational framework I mean just
to give an example you just use the term
white supremacist and that's something
which because I don't have the framework
to understand that that seems in I mean
to be honest it is something that makes
me a little bit uncomfortable because it
when it's used oh um that person is
saying something that person is part of
the white supremacist metamarrative or
something like that that feels like I'm
being essentialized sure
so um so so which is the right framework
to use how do we know
yeah well you know the snappy smart ass
answer would be to say that they're
asking that there's a single right
framework as itself a problem right no
no but I mean you know there clearly
isn't one right framework but I totally
um I would like to respond to what
you're saying about the kind of a
centralizing thing because actually a
minute ago when we were chatting about
stuff I did remember
you know
that an important aspect for me of this
is is what you might call
psychopolitical in the sense that
um what's present in all these things
what's present in our our interaction
was present in our social structures and
what's present in
the conception of what technologies can
be and do
um are not just conscious but
unconscious
um
psychodynamic uh
energies and effects and and lineages
and connections and
I guess I've got to a stage now where
because it's been kind of
um
rightly brought to my attention in
enough places in enough different ways
you know that I I'm okay now I
I can understand actually that I am
hugely privileged you know that I do
have incredible advantages
compared to some people's experience of
life
actually basically because of being a
middle class white male with a good
education I mean that is
um you know
that's literally money in the bank but
it's more than that it's Social Capital
that has um preserved me and extended me
in ways that other people simply don't
have a chance to have now that doesn't
mean I'm a bad person
that's just
where I have what the things I happen to
be born into in some extent and
experience in other ways and and be
gifted in other ways and it's not that's
I don't think that's a condemnation of
me
unless perhaps I refuse to recognize it
or unless perhaps I didn't then think
about what am I going to do with this so
I I just think it firstly that it's not
I don't think these things should be
read as a condemnation of any individual
or or even or social group as such but
it does lead into your other question
you know what's the right thing to do if
you like it enough that's a you know
very long
question has a huge lineage you know
um
I I'm not trying to for myself work from
or through any of the things that I
write a single version of that I'm not
trying to impose
um
a particular communist vision of the
world or a particular set of
relationalities but my idea of
relational thinking and understanding
um definitely not involved informed by
Jordan Peterson would be much more
informed by feminism who I think
feminist thinking
from the same kind of period actually
from back in the 60s onwards has had
this understanding of how to you know
read life and understand society as
primarily relational
um
with consequences what are the
consequences of that and the
consequences are not just there are
relations but um
as you all know because you've read the
book you've had looked through the book
you know the idea of care is is kind of
important in the second half of the book
and that arises out of this feminist
idea of relationality in the sense of
you know as a simple rule of thumb as a
heuristic to understand you know when I
go into college and it's you know let's
say it's the first lecture of the day
and it's the early morning shift and all
the cleaners coming out of are coming
out of college in their you know with
their massive sets of keys or whatever
and they're all black women
and I'm a white man walking in there to
do the lecture that is a very
particular kind of relationality there's
a very particular set of
um
very asymmetric
power relation and those people's
experiences are very strongly affected
by
their situatedness so what happens I
mean
Goldsmith I think has been people at
Goldsmith the staff at Cosmos have
had a long struggle to
bring workers like that as they say back
in house to make sure that they do have
some at least decent minimal terms and
conditions they're not you know
instantly dismissable because they're
just some poor paid contract worker but
they at least have some proper
relationship with work that they have
some proper enumeration that they have
sick pay and all that kind of thing I'm
not trying to portray
that's to me is
um
it's not equalizing but some element of
equitability you know if if you see
others
who need care in some way who are
suffering in some way
why are you not motivated to do
something about that
would is the question I asked myself
[Music]
could could you just quickly
could you just quickly speak to because
you spoke about I think the the second
wave of of feminism and and you were
just getting on to the social care and
emancipation and so on but um but now I
I think we we are in the the regime of
intersectional feminism just to explain
the the difference a little bit to the
audience and how it's evolved
I think intersectionality is a good is a
good uh starting point
for the kind of
social thinking that I try to do
alongside the thinking about the
machines or thinking about the
technology I mean intersectionality
um as a political concept would probably
be
looking at these different ways of
um assessing
asymmetries in society the sort of
topographies of inequality and radically
different experience so those might be
which supportively said class
gender race let's say
intersectionality would be and has been
articulated by a particular thinkers you
know in recent history
would be to say
um
is is to assert the inseparability of
those things in some way you know rather
than the Primacy I mean the Primacy
problem might have come from well from
different dimensions but it might be
that uh you know let's say it might be
if there was a form of feminism that was
asserting that the gender divide was the
primary problem
or the classified or the race race
inequalities are primary problem but
they're entangled yeah they're saying
entangled and entangled as you know
I think entangled you know that term is
really much more helpful
tool to look at
those experiences that sociality and
also the impacts of Technology
interesting and um
the traditional let was focused on
social class in particular and and now
we're speaking about this entanglement
between different identities like
um sex and sexuality and and race and so
on um I just wondered how how did how
did that come about and how is it um
affected the the left viewpoint
well speaking as a spokesperson for the
left Viewpoint
um I'm sorry I'm only kidding no no
because
well anyway also I'd say that's a bit of
a story actually you know right that um
yeah there was an attempt to sort of
um
establish that as a dominant framework
on let's say progressive thinking or
whatever you might want to call it at a
certain point in time but
history is is is such an interesting you
know patch of Earth to dig in because it
always turns out that things are always
more complicated
and the people's ideas of what
Liberation might be we're always I mean
intersectionality is a kind of minimal
you know there are many times many
different ways people have always
thought of this in a much more
pluralistic sense which is great you
know because it's that
is clearly uh you know I I think that's
that's uh
clearly much more helpful because that
our experiences of Life are
uh shaped by so many different
forces and sometimes they are very
forceful forces and two it's impossible
I think to Simply pick on one and say
this is a I mean for particular people
one might be the most dominant one but
they're certainly not the only one for
anybody
and the entanglement
of the unfolding of history and also
very particularly the unfolding of
History alongside those things we tend
to think of as technology on machines or
mechanical
mechanisms you know those
those entanglements are always plural
amongst all of those lines so
um it isn't only like it's a matter of
left history but it's also a matter of
let's say
considering
um
politics in that way you know that
if that is in in a sense some kind of
politics then actually
the thing I'm most interested is trying
to think about technopolitics trying to
think about those things inseparably you
know what is it about particular ways of
ordering Society
okay through largely through production
but also through social reproduction
with various kinds of machines and
Technologies and infrastructures
they're constantly sort of layer over
the top of each other you know the way
Fiber Optic Cables you know recapitulate
those patterns of telegraph lines across
the Atlantic and you know I mean that's
a very physical instantiation but they
both on the material and the semantic
sense these
structures and machines they lay on top
of each other you know what ways these
shape these other really important
experiences of life these in sectional
relations
um
and how that pans out for each and every
one of us yeah that makes sense so the
way the way I understand it because I
can use an analogy in machine learning
some people think that we should design
a structure a lens and some people say
oh it's just too complicated you must
let it emerge a bit but in a way you're
talking to there is a a structure in
society and it's entangled in a very
complicated way and that relational
topology kind of defines the world that
we live in our reality to a certain
extent so there's a real Focus to shine
a light on that structure
yeah I think I think it's in
both to see what it's doing at the
moment and also to see what else it
could be doing
yes okay okay let's move on to your
article about chat gbt now this was a
very very interesting article um Emily
Bender retweeted it which is how I
discovered you but um it was called we
come to bury chat GPT not to praise it
so um summarizing a little bit you said
chat GPT is a generator that
produces baseless assertions with
unfailing confidence and the more
optimized chat GPT becomes the more
harmful it is as it hallucinates
um even more and they become harder to
spot
um reinforcement learning from Human
feedback only makes it better for
um you know better at bullshitting
basically not a not a a reliable AI the
concept of AGI you said is inseparable
from the hierarchy of intelligence that
is underpinned ideas of innate Supremacy
which we just spoke to a bit
um he said that contemporary AI is an
assemblage for automating administrative
violence and amplifying austerity and AI
realism is a form of hopelessness that
accepts ai's potential harms without
questioning its speculative benefits and
also the structural injustices and
supremacist perspectives layered into AI
put it on the path of eugenesis
solutions to social problems which again
we spoke to a little bit and finally you
said that AI Technologies in in prison
our ability to imagine real Alternatives
and we should focus on socially useful
production instead so
um let's start with the
generator thing
um you know why are we so easily fooled
by its smooth talking hmm
uh
so you were saying that article is a bit
of a rant
would I would I say that would I say
that it was a good rat yeah I enjoyed
reading it very much I'm glad they got
it out of my system uh yeah yeah so
that's a really great question why why
are we so susceptible to
um I mean just just to explain myself
you know I'm saying it's
because it's uh
I suppose a combination of two things it
is to me literally meaningless the
output of that Machinery is literally
meaningless could you explain why
yeah because it's the product of
machinic calculation you know
statistical uh
statistical reproduction of patterns
learned through the ingestion of lots of
text
and it's producing tokens in an order
that is statistically you know through
through quite complicated model as like
transform model you know but it's
essentially a statistical pattern
learning machine that does a lot of a
lot more convincing job of producing
patterns but that's the point that
convincing is at our end not at the
machine end the machine is simply
carrying out
optimizable calculations to produce
tokens and is uh
that that process is optimized
mathematically
it produces these tokens in ways that
come across to us as
having meaning or possibly even
convincing and possibly even insightful
that's us doing that
um kind of that's us looking in the
mirror Darkly in a way and and becoming
Amazed by our own insights uh rehashed
back to us in some way
but also you know there is something
really disingenuous about
these particular models open AI again
you know they are
that the tonality of those things is not
accidental you know it is it is
trying to sound
mostly authoritative or even by
sometimes apologizing and correcting
itself trying to sound perhaps more than
authoritative but like you know it's
something you can trust because it's
admitting to some extent some
infallibility
yeah that's something I have a
particular problem with chat GPT it uses
um emoticons
and um you know smiley faces and
apologies so so that that increases the
risk of anthropomorphization but I did
want to just tease apart a little bit
though that because you was kind of
saying it doesn't understand and I don't
know whether it's because you think that
no machine could understand or
do you think there is a spectrum of
understanding I mean is it possible to
have a slightly lower Fidelity
understanding but still an understanding
nonetheless
to mean it doesn't there's no
understanding in there to me it's you
know it's a music box
so what what's your definition of
understanding
um
I wouldn't have a pat one
okay I mean I would say for me meaning
is
uh comes out of those relations we were
talking about early on
um with
um well with beings
also with the natural world
um and the material world it's not that
I think
um these machines themselves have no
meaning clearly they have a huge sets of
meanings
but
I find it I don't find it plausible that
there's any
use the things you brought up earlier on
in sort of introspection
or contemplation of a kind that I would
understand that I would
empathize with that I could relate to
you know perhaps there are ways of
philosophically describing what's going
on in those machines in a way that can
situate them as you know cognition in
some way and that's fine
do you do that
um I don't literally care I'm interested
in
what this particular machine constructed
in this particular way
is clearly already doing in the world
and that is
in my opinion falsely persuading people
that it has some level of insight
minimal or maximal into any particular
situation and and there's more to it
than that it's not even that
people believe that it that a large
language model necessarily understands
those things they think it's kind of a
good enough start to understand those
things and I'm quite concerned about
what's already lost in that good enough
start you know there's a lot of that in
the space I the Fishbowl I'm in for
Education here going well you know you
need to embrace chat gbt and of course
it's not perfect and it gets things
wrong and um misunderstands you know
assuming that understands anything but
you know that's something we can work
with we can use that with students and
you know make it a
you know make it the start of exercises
and when are we what's a great way to
teach critical thinking is to you know
that that's a second order move and say
yeah okay this machine
uh produces some complete Fabrications
that's a great provocation to you know
critical thinking and um I my personal
feeling is if you start that way you've
already lost and so yeah so I don't
attribute any I personally don't
attribute any thought process to it you
can
that's fine but let's look at the
consequences of doing that
and the consequences of doing that and
what what I kind of
tried to inject into the short piece you
describe also was
um related to some other video I've been
doing recently of something much
different which is
European Union policies and Frameworks
for AI you know which is
a pretty big thing in a way because that
we're talking there about
um
huge institutional commitments huge
investment
a shaping you know we were talking
you've talked we've both talked quite a
lot about
um the shaping of our worlds I mean
whatever we think of the EU and you know
allegedly we're sort of somewhat outside
it right here right now which is a bit
implausible the effects of it will
definitely be felt and
the primary principle
my reading of those long and extremely
tedious and I'd say deliberately to
these documents is first off the EU is
100 committed to do it to AI the future
if they see the future of the EU
h
3 AI two reasons uh economic obviously
and because that's the kind of
extent understanding and also
geopolitically
you know I think something you said
earlier reminded me of that I mean these
things are you know these are the
geopolitics of our time as well so you
know the Europeans who are China over
there USA over there we're Europe we
want to be a thing so they're totally
important
but the point of this long Preamble is
that their
skeleton key for all this is trustable
AI okay being the you
they're taking on you know the fact that
this isn't always an untrammeled a good
thing that there may be some drawbacks
and uh you know some downsides and
biases whatever so they're very
concerned that we should that well they
what they say they're concerned about is
producing trustable AI what they're
really concerned about then it's pretty
transparent is that we just trust AI
yes right because actually they haven't
got any other way of getting trusted by
the eye other than the AI we've got and
they're in a great hurry to get on with
it so I'm putting those two things
alongside each other because I'm saying
okay well we might have a different idea
about cognition might have a different
idea about what these things are doing
but let's look at the work they're doing
in the world
and when you start to buy in that these
things are producing some kind of
insight and some kind of truth then well
as a that was the connection I was
trying to make in the article your your
shortcutting to what the EU is already
trying to get to these things can be
trusted you're also opening up a huge
range of other areas like something that
has come up a little bit in our you know
our brief exchanges before talking today
is you know some of the impacts on and
through mental health
if you ascribe some kind of insights
these machines then it's actually would
be ridiculous not to apply them
in therapeutic and diagnostic settings
which again is another area for me and I
suspect we're about to discuss it a bit
you know is would be extremely dangerous
I mean first of all um the AI we have
now is is not robust it's trained on the
conspiracy Laden internet
um but it is fine-tuned with rlhf and
you're speaking to the students and
unfortunately a lot of the mistakes
are under the radar because it produces
plausible text and when you use these
things for an extended period of time um
it Dawns on you after a while I think
there's when you first use gpt4 it is
genuinely amazing I have to say but but
um you have the halo effect and then
over time you start to notice these
errors and it Dawns on you that you've
missed lots of other ones before
um but um yeah so it's it's not it's not
reliable
at all yes yes I mean I love that I love
the academic citations thing because
it's quite good at generating really
plausible sounding papers with real
authors you know who genuinely work in
that particular area yes it's only that
that particular paper doesn't exist or
the classic one in our case talking to
the students and colleagues in Computing
is the well I mean I say hilarious but I
think it hasn't always been a good
experience where in some cases smaller
companies uh are you know are getting
hammered you know uh or their apis
getting hammered because GPT has told
somebody that this their API does this
thing it doesn't do and of course all
these people putting this question into
to
um GPT three or four or whatever it is
and they're getting told yeah this is
the answer to your
you know this is the technique this is
the code you need it uses this API it
doesn't exist
I can really relate to that argument so
I think it is polluting the info sphere
um dramatically
but the thing I want to tease apart is
we're speaking about the AI as if it
exists on its own and if anything I want
to bring in this entangled idea that we
had before which is that humans use AI
and yeah maybe they'll have a bit of
critical thinking I I don't know but
don't don't we have to actually think
because it's it's it's not really
artificial intelligence yes it's neither
artificial nor intelligence and
according to um what was that lady's
name she wrote the um the atlas okay
Crawford yeah yeah
so um why don't we just think of it as a
tool in meshed and and embedded in
society would that be a different lens
yeah it definitely would and a much
better one much more important one but
you know one that then I think actually
forefronts are problematics not like a
closing door you know it's not like I'm
saying oh yeah we should definitely get
rid of all technology Beyond um pullers
and levers or something like that
necessarily but um you know
it is it is the right situation because
it uh I think the way you describe it
encompasses the bit that we really most
often ignore which is where this stuff
come from in the first place you know so
much of the narrative around
um you know deep learning or machine
learning models or whatever it is
um
really seem to have an imaginary where
the stuff is created somewhat outside of
society whether it's in the hallowed
Halls of Microsoft research or wherever
else it is or Academia
you know by incredibly bright people who
understand maths and computing
um
you know
while those while the values of those
people on their motives might be
questioned it's as if this thing is
created in within a sphere of its own
and it needs to be ported across into
society and we need to be careful about
how we do that because it might we might
tip balances some in some way and we
might create biases and discriminations
and maybe it does have some other
downsides that we haven't even thought
of
um
but
I don't know when people think about it
like that but they talk about it like
that and that completely misses the
point that's very very not even latent
but explicitly in your
description which is these these don't
come from somewhere else these
Technologies were developed within the
society that we all know we are all
experts in experience
of this Society of whichever Society it
is that we live in right we're already
the experts because we live in it and
these Technologies however complicated
they are and they are complicated and
actually you know
I can look at these things as much as I
can understand them and go do you know
what that's pretty clever that is a nice
trick that's a nice piece of I think of
it as like technical jiu jitsu you know
that I can appreciate that you know I
have a that background in science and
background in in sort of
an analytical perspective on the world
and you know I I I can I can dig it
but
the idea the most important thing to
remember is really that it
it emerges out of the same Matrix that
it's going to go straight back into the
feedback loops don't start then they
already
they're coming at this very Inception
it's shaping so you know the idea that
we could ever
unentangle these things is is uh is
patently absurd and I think it's that's
why I at the moment what I'm working on
really is trying to Define for myself a
more useful concept of this idea of
technopolitics meaning
that um
because I'm interested in in the
political small P aspect of it you know
that these are
highly impactful on uh
say power relations production
distribution that meaning of political
and that the kinds of technologies that
the Techno part of that is inseparable
from that shapes that and is shaped by
it
and you could say that
you know
people who understood that for example
with the luddites you know they had it
they had they had a grasp on the idea
that these things that were being
introduced as new forms of productivity
were in fact
world-changing
for them in their immediate sense but
you wouldn't describe yourself as a
Luddite well I probably would yeah oh
you would okay right I probably would
yes or I don't know and Neo yeah I think
let that is good interesting but the
reason I asked that question is
um you're still a technologist you love
computers yeah so how do you square that
that's kind of tussle yeah I swear that
because I'm not buying into the idea of
of Luddite that you know again that
historical story you know which
come on I mean it is largely pivoted on
you know these people didn't get
the necessity of Technology you know
they were kind of they were primitivists
in some way they were backward looking
regressive you know I mean there's so
much to read in in that you know the
idea that
um
increased productivity means progress
necessarily
um or untrammeled productivity means
progress
um in any case whichever Dimension you
take on it's a total misunderstanding I
think you know we could say on the best
historical evidence of what the loadouts
were really about you know the luddites
used machines themselves
they went against technology
what they what they were questioning in
my in my opinion
were the radical alterations in in
the social relations that were coming
about as a result of these particular
kind of machines
and their particular Arrangements of
ownership and control
interesting but you have said that you
think AI is a scam
it you did on on a YouTube Interview
then I said it okay yes yes and I
convert the reference in but yeah but um
but the the concept like a bit of
context because um a question came up in
that YouTube interview and the gentleman
asked could you imagine a society where
AI could possibly be good and you said
um to be honest
if we lived in a good Society the the
phenomenon of AI couldn't emerge or
wouldn't emerge or something along those
lines
so I find that a little bit difficult to
get my head around because I still have
this mindset of I can imagine a world
where AI could be beneficial
yeah
well you know
I'm not trying to tell you you're wrong
I'm just trying to express my own
reading of the current moment
um I would very much like it if we
stepped back from
uh actually multiple of the technologies
that we currently have including Ai and
and
like quite a long way back
um because of the assumptions that are
not just the assumptions but the
modes of production that are actually
already enrolled in these things you
know the
let's look at something you mentioned a
minute ago about
um
rlhf
I put it right overnight reinforcement
learning with you always get that wrong
uh in my head
I think what for example what that
suggests to me is that
um
our understanding of machine learning is
already very skewed because
there is thankfully you know as they say
a lot of critical scholarship about this
kind of stuff and more than that there's
there's an awareness amongst uh at least
let's say activist communities or
amongst um workers themselves that
there's a heck of a lot of invisible
labor goes into these things now
um I think language models are a really
interesting example because they're
self-supervised learning at the
primarily you know which was always the
thing I remember only a few years ago
you know people are saying that that's
the that's some kind of Grail you know
and that will allow us to move past this
uh awkward Reliance on you know
extremely underpaid and exploited
crowdsourced labor right swung the other
way yeah well well and you know and it
what I think what I'd read from that you
know is uh some kind of law of AI
actually that uh here's his prediction
for somebody who complains about
predictions that
it will turn out that no form of AI as
we can currently conceive it
um
will be operational
without
somewhere at some point and probably at
several points a massive injection
of
devalued human labor and that's my kind
of beef with it as well you know that
bigging up
the computational operations and the
models and the engineering and
everything else is entirely ignoring
who's making this stuff actually work
and that comes in a minute okay it comes
in at the poor people who had to go
through the you know um
bestiality and child abuse content and
remove it from yeah uh you know GPT
models that's one variance of it but
I think you know as you look around you
see many different examples that when
for example when
applications you sort of find hard to
argue with you know the ones have been
happening with the NHS well you know
we've got a model here that will
allow the early prediction of kidney
problems or something like that you know
as it turns out when these systems are
introduced into real world settings
let's say out of the lab
you know life is just a lot more
complicated and messy and so are people
and basically so is everything else I
mean even materiality is much more
complicated messy and it always needs
um a huge amount of sort of compensatory
human work and Care actually to keep the
thing afloat and
weirdly I'm I'm working myself up here a
little bit but I think I do get kind of
quite marked by the idea that
um
what seems to be happening is that we're
having to spend a lot of time caring for
the technology
which is supposedly providing the answer
to our problems of care when actually we
could probably short-circuit that by
actually just caring for each other in
the first place a bit more effectively
so so yeah I do think
you know we can explore the different
aspects I do think there are many
aspects of the Dynamics of currently
understood definitely deep learning and
all its Associated methodologies
Transformer models or reinforcement
learning whatever
and even machine learning to a large
extent
that are sufficiently problematic
in terms of their effects in the world
that it would be a good idea to step
back from them not to say that the
people involved in it have always been
trying to to do bad things by a long
truck that's not the case
and I think people with Technologic
technological
or technical skills mathematical skills
and scientific skills and understandings
um
you know again our well-being is
entangled with that you know we're not
we're not going to have a good world
without those kind of skills
but uh you know we can look at the
general direction of travel of of
societies in general and say
um
you know
those things look like they need
reorienting pretty majorly
um
for because the social impacts and also
because of the planetary impacts
you said something interesting which is
that it's becoming increasingly clear
how exploitative this technology is and
part of the reason for that is the
increased necessity for humans to do the
fine-tuning on on the model and there
was that story you referred to with open
AI
um using that company called samarin in
Africa but
um it's one interesting Trend I've seen
is that open AI it's not open anymore
it's become increasingly closed up but
but actually you could argue it's the
competitive landscape but you could also
argue that it's becoming increasingly
clear to everyone how exploited the
technology is and um
a few years ago when gbt3 came out
everyone thought oh this is amazing
they've just taken the common cruel
Corpus
um and it's a reasonably well-known data
set and they've just trained it and oh
we've got an AI and over time presumably
they've had to
Outsource lots of different types of
data we don't know where from they won't
tell us yes and they'll do all of this
reinforcement learning preference tuning
we don't know they don't tell us
anything about it and it's becoming
completely obscure and you probably read
that ethics washing piece from outman
the other day talking all about how
they're going to align the models and
how they're such wonderful people I mean
what did you think about that
um yeah
I think the word align itself is very
revealing isn't it and you know you know
obviously from even from the previous
conversations you've had and that the
word alignment is itself a kind of
keyword
that that alignment is used often to
indicate it's almost a kind of um
it's almost a kind of gang sign you know
it's like yeah we're down with the AGI
crew here you know we see the future
benefits of these things
um as sort of uh sufficiently
you know at sort of um Beyond planetary
scale
you know
so yeah they're eating they're he's
reading a kind of uh
large language models for good
bedtime story but it's also really
distilled through this perspective on
what a you know almost kind of what the
inevitable planetary situation must be
and that those assumptions in themselves
we talk you know we we kind of name
checked the long-termest view you know
the space-faring super race of virtual
beings type of view of reality now
whatever you know I'm quite into science
fiction as well you know you won't be
surprised to hear yeah yeah I mean the
Boston stuff yeah well yeah you know
it's it's
fine as a kind of science fiction story
in in a way but
they take it incredibly seriously yeah
yeah that's right I mean
it's interesting to me that the
well interesting might not be quite the
right word I'm chilling perhaps it's a
good word the the uh you know that these
concepts of a necessity
for let's say
radical risk reduction you know in this
concept of risk you know seems to chime
so well again with
um
historical parallels I mean recent
historical powers in this case there was
a guy called
Harden I've forgot his first name at the
moment he was the one who came who wrote
the very influential paper on the idea
of the tragedy of the commons yes
Garrett Hardin
he was also a guy who wrote quite uh
extensively on this idea of Lifeboat
ethics hmm
it's pretty obvious stuff you know
you're in a Lifeboat it can only take 30
people you've already got 35 in the boat
and there are other people swimming
around in the sea
you have no choice you know if they grab
the boat you hit him with a hammer
that's uh
I'm bringing that up because I honestly
think that something similar is emerging
in this Nexus between
um techno philosophy let's say these
ideas like long-termism
even effective altruism
and
real material crises
climate change the large-scale movement
of people due to climate change and
other disruptions like the ongoing
colonialism and War
that that um there's a agglomeration
or a kind of convergence of uh
perspectives within all of these things
that
um sees it as regrettably necessary to
to defend certain portions of
uh of Life lived experience by whatever
means necessary and weirdly just to
bring the EU back into the middle of
that that's
um pretty evident in EU border policy
which uncoincidentally is where they see
a lot of the applications of AI beings
all of these things I know I'm
joining a lot of trying to join a lot of
Dots here and fold things over like some
kind of mad recipe but I think this is
entanglement this is how these things uh
play into each other and play back on
each other
and for each of us you know we need to
try to develop a
you know uh
free to us we need to try to develop a
working picture a working understanding
of what that means for us and ours the
people that we care about and the world
that we care about and what we're going
to do about it and
um
the urgency for me around the AI that we
have is that it's currently unreflective
uh development application
unthinkingly or through the
encouragement of unthinking-ness
plays right into the hands of uh
these very regressive agendas
and uh
with such force that it's basically
impossible to conceive of an AI for good
at this moment in time
now um you said
saying as the open AI CEO so Sam outman
again that we're all stochastic parrots
just like large language models
statistical generators of learned
patterns that Express nothing deeper now
you said that was a form of nihilism
what do you mean by that
um well I'm
handily citing someone else
when I say that but but it
but you think there's something deeper
to human intelligence
is is that is that the thing
yeah I don't think
I was having an interesting argument
about this on social media as you do
only yesterday and
I love the
discourse around language you know
clearly this is kind of a demonstration
of its very nature right the idea that
more than language dialogue you know is
um
you know critical to whatever it means
to have communication and understanding
and
you know there's other things we've been
talking about meaning
um
and actually that's why you know in the
book I do put quite a lot of emphasis on
uh
spaces for Collective discourse about
things that need to be done you know
which which I would put under
titles of things like workers councils
and people's councils but that's
essentially what it is because those are
transformative spaces I mean to some you
know small alert extent we come out of
this conversation different than when we
went into it so
so I'm saying all that because
I don't want to end anywhere under mine
uh the importance of language and and
speech and discourse which of course is
what um something like a large language
model seems to do I mean I'd say it
isn't doing that at all it's it's doing
maths which is fine
but um I quite like maths I don't think
it's the same thing
um
because I don't think that for example I
think this actually is probably pretty
indisputable that if I have a
conversation
quote unquote in my terms with uh gpt4
let's say
um well maybe I might change as part of
that experience but it isn't going to uh
other than
perhaps you know ingesting its
interaction with me and mathematically
tuning its model to be a little bit more
plausible next time that's not what I
mean you know I'm might transform my
understanding of the world or what I
attribute value and meaning to
um
yeah yeah there is a
a singular mathematical value in what
those machines are doing they're
optimizing
their mathematical output their loss
functional cost function whatever it is
so uh having said that in a long-winded
way there's clearly more to being alive
Than Words you know embodied experience
meaning
and emotion and empathy and
understanding
um
what I care about
I mean in so many ways I agree with you
I was very influenced by seoul's Chinese
room argument um which is basically
saying that syntax
or semantics can't be derived from
syntax so from the form of language but
there are papers coming out that are
showing that language models trained on
the form of language can represent in a
vector space a lot of things that we
thought were in the realm of the subject
of experience right for example color
representation yeah and I think
everyone's pleasantly surprised by the
receding Horizon I still believe that it
it can't recede much more but there does
appear to be a lot of the subjective
experience captured in these models it's
a bit of a mystery
yeah well I'm not saying yeah about the
mystery bit so much as I agree with you
in terms of the things that uh these
machines will
you know can do I mean before the
language models are you know the idea of
um
image recognition convolutional neural
networks could be trained to
uh recognize faces first off and could
do so you know under
conditions of occlusion at a distance or
perhaps gate though those kind of really
um probably everyone has had that
experience of waiting for a friend you
know perhaps uh the light's not so good
and you see them from a distance you
need to know who they are and that feels
like a moment of connection and
um not something that you'd expect a
machine to be able to reproduce and they
can
and uh
I don't know whether I'm being obtuse
that doesn't give me any sense
that the machine is doing anything
even like what I'm doing when I you know
there's an there's an emulation some
sense of that I recognize that person's
gate to the distance they have learned
to recognize that put
so I think recognition would be a fair
statement you know that they would
produce an output
that would classify it as that person
under those conditions
that's fine I mean when I see that
person what's my experience my
experience of is of all the things that
person means to me of all those shared
experiences
there's there's things we've done
together said to each other
um experiences we've had
or recounted to each other what it means
to be there waiting for that person at
that moment
it's fine if you think that the language
model is working towards that
then I'm not here to prove you wrong uh
I don't believe it from moment
I do struggle a bit with the
overwhelming force of people's wish to
believe in these things that does seem
to be very dominant at the moment and to
be honest it's like really wearing
um yes but uh
where I challenge you and we're probably
going to answer a bit of that in a
specific context as well is that okay
you think that I don't think that but
let's look at the consequences of those
thoughts
of those beliefs
what are the consequences and and it's
two-way you know you can say to me well
the consequence is your belief are that
we're going to lose all these
opportunities we're perhaps going to
leave people in a worse situation they
might have been because these things can
be helpful and I'd be saying to you
that your beliefs are
harmful
and complicit in forms of institutional
and social violence so you know that's
maybe
where the cookie crumbles for me you
know it's I'm not trying to convince you
of a particular model of cognition
um I'm trying to say
I'm happy to explain what mine is but
mainly I'm concerned about where does
that lead us
it could be we'll segue back onto this
point in a minute but on on this
understanding point in particular
there's philosophers have been talking
about this for a very long time starting
with Descartes and mind-body dualism and
so one of his thought experiments was
the essentially the um the ontological
difference in understanding between
someone who laughed at a joke right and
um the computer just doing the the
symbol manipulation yeah there's clearly
an ontological difference yeah and
understanding is is about all of these
contextual factors that you spoke of
whether it's semantics or pragmatics or
the context the purpose
etc etc
so but then you could argue I mean as
David Chalmers did you could have a
philosophical zombie which is you take a
complete copy of a human atom by atom
and they might behaviorally represent a
human and be indistinguishable mimicry
on a level which is indistinguishable
but they don't have conscious experience
so you could always make the argue that
there's something extra which is not
captured by the system but then I would
I would say to you what if you did have
an AI which was
a perfect form of mimicry a perfect form
of representation
would you still think it was harmful
these are
good questions you'll be glad to hear in
my opinion right no because that's but
I'm gonna I'm gonna step sideways and
say that's a philosophical question
right right and it's that's good right I
think philosophical questions are very
useful
um uh you know because we all have a
philosophy whether we whether we like it
or not whether we think of it or not we
all have a philosophy or like a mangled
versions of philosophy we have to in
order to deliver we have to have an
understanding of what it is to live and
what life means and what's important and
everything else and they do whether we
like it or not I know it or not you know
they have what other people would
describe as epistemologies and
ontology's wrapped up in them
and philosophy serves a really useful
space there for
actually stepping back from those things
and and sort of coming at them from a
different angle as you you were just
doing and uh I would just say that's a
thought experiment okay which is great
you know and thought experiments are
really important in physics which is
like my you know starting point
um but they are thought experiments and
it's uh you know quite dangerous to I
think
can be quite dangerous can be risky to
adopt those thought experiments as other
than thought experiments I mean actually
I was teaching the ethics I teach of
course in ethical Computing you won't be
surprised to hear and uh you know we
were looking at self-driving cars yes
right and the trolley problem you know
the trolley problem is a thought
experiment that's meant to illustrate
actually weirdly given our current times
you know was really brought to
prominence in debates around abortion
you know back in back in the 60s around
around the Roe versus Wade decision you
know that was a philosophical debate
those were
those are
philosophical stance is meant to bring
out in US
uh aspects of a situation that we had
maybe left unconsidered or under
considered
they weren't meant to be interpreted
literally as something you should
program into a
you know a two-ton piece of fast-moving
metal as a way to decide how to Target
itself that's that it's a thought
experiment it's not an adequate
you know uh
operational ethics and
something similar about this is like
it's it's quite
I'm sure it's fruitful
to consider that that isn't
my
uh priority my priority is to consider
what I can materially see these machines
are doing
at this moment in time and what their
capacity seem to be and what impacts
that has in the world so
um could I push back on that yeah you
mentioned the Lifeboat example before
and and we need we need philosophy to
give us something which is fruitful and
operational we do otherwise there's
almost
no point in doing it I mean fluoridi
said to us by the way that that
philosophy should have a purpose there's
no point in philosophers problems but in
this particular case isn't it quite
similar to um when we speak about the
um emancipation and so on and and even
deleterious effects on society um isn't
that as a similar form of trolley
problem
uh well lucky for me that I said thought
experience was useful oh good yeah you
know but but my thought experiments are
meant to be interpreted
uh as you know
full descriptions of reality or
statements of fact or
um ideological prescriptions or anything
else I mean
I don't know what it what what
your line of questioning makes me think
is or what it makes me want to respond
is like I don't think we should really
rely on philosophers yes to guide life
or Society I mean that was
well you know that was Plato I think and
that didn't sound particularly fun to me
although there are instantiations of
societies right now which seem
uncomfortably close to that
I think um
philosophy is a very fruitful domain
um we need we will have philosophies we
need to
have ways to develop our philosophies
but at the end we shouldn't rely on
philosophers to tell us what to do or to
describe reality they they have a
particular capacity and that's what
they're doing
the people who should be defining
reality is us who are living it you know
my rule of thumb would be uh well
actually maybe take something from the
disability movements you know which have
a slogan since I don't know from a long
time ago nothing about us without us
you know that that
if something is being made or done or
arranged that's going to affect your
life you should have a say in it you
should have a say in it not that it
should be guided by your favorite
philosopher or somebody else's favorite
philosopher philosophy is fine but I'm
not gonna
arrange my life according to this
philosopher or that philosopher or rely
on them it's only us that life is a very
complex complicated messy business and
each time that's why dialogue's so
important we have to have that kind of
discourse two together address the
particular thing we're facing at that
moment together is is abstraction itself
part of the problem or maybe
reductionism is a word you would prefer
because in this trolley problem what
they've done is they've removed as many
details as possible yeah that's the
design yeah and and that that's that's
the issue yes yes I mean you're right
and and I thought I saw a nice term for
it actually as I was kind of reading
back on that stuff and you know it's uh
it's a subset called a quandary problem
you know you remove all these
uncertainties like you say all of the in
fact importantly all of the other things
you could have already done yes to start
that situation you just put yourself in
the urgency but
um more importantly
the problem you
you put your pose there or this idea you
know what's the kind of um effect of
abstraction or reduction I mean
I think right at this moment I would say
that I
I don't have a problem with abstraction
or even reduction in some way they don't
you know they seem to be tactics
you know I I'm I guess I'm doing it
right now you know I'm having to
um
schematize some of the stuff we're
talking about because the otherwise the
complexities would be overwhelming as a
way of navigating my through it's like
it's the climbing wall again and I'm
finding trying to find footholds in
order to keep moving I think it's the
it's idolatry that I'm concerned about
it's like reifying those things as if
they are
um
more profound
uh more authoritative
than what
people happen to be really experiencing
in their lives at any given moment so
it's not so much the idea that
abstraction
you know you mustn't abstract things I
don't think we have that choice or that
you mustn't sometimes reduce things but
there's a kind of there's another end to
that process as well right you reduce
things and Abstract things in order to
come back out again in order to come
back to
shared lived experience I think it's
about grounding then so the um you could
go to the platonic realm where there's
no grounding in in reality at all and
then there's there's these planes of
reality and and you think the the
appropriate plane to ground things in is
the reality of our experience
yeah I mean you know there's there's
probably a lot of um philosophical traps
I'm in danger of sticking my foot right
into here in terms of um you know the
sort of recursiveness recursiveness of
these things which which I think that's
one thing one thing computer science has
given to the world is an enhanced
awareness of recursiveness and and it's
kind of ever presence in our in our ways
of thinking about things because you
know even when we're thinking about
thought we're using thought to do that
you know yes so so I think recursiveness
is always like a really good thing to
bear in mind that's kind of inescapable
um
yeah so so you're asking about the the
kind of grounding yeah
um
I think my
you know I've quite enough you know
having having kind of dist philosophy
I've got quite an affinity with process
philosophy
in the sense that you know it's it's
trying to remove our Focus
from the fixed
you know to my reading of it anyway you
know towards the becoming
and I think
if if I was uh committed to something
it's to the becomings you know uh um and
I I I guess pragmatically it seems to me
that those becomings are
shared a share you know a shared product
um
or imposed you know they're shared or
imposed and that's not an absolute
division either because all these things
are binaries but I'm
mostly opposed to the imposed and mostly
committed to the shared
yes and I think there's an interesting
metaphor or analogy here with part of
the problem with AI models is is the
sclerotic
um representational nature which is to
say they they just take a snapshot and
reinforce the status quo and similarly
with the process philosophy
um you you don't like this sclerotic
nature you you prefer to think of a
trajectory to somewhere rather than
where we are now yes well it's not
always Dynamic unfolding that gives us a
possibility for change as well you know
and I I guess to me you know my
psychopolitics is that
um
what keeps me going is a belief in the
possibility of change you know that
would be my
dead end on that though with
progressivism in in general is that
focus on the philosophy of change a
function of you not being happy with the
status quo I mean if we were in a world
which you were completely content would
that philosophy chain
yeah well you know I'm sure my wife
would said it'd be very difficult to
conceive of a world in which I was
completely content you know
um
and actually I don't think there would
be one you know in in the sense that
surely content and discontent are always
you know again a kind of binary uh it's
life I don't know I'm I've I've
accumulated a number of years of
experience of life and then I built
right and uh you know it's it's messy
and it's complicated and it's quite
often painful and uh compromising and
I've now at my age done so many things
that I said I would never say or do or
you know
um
that that I don't see some kind of uh
certainly not a static Utopia but I'm a
utopian in the sense that I believe
there are many possibilities that are
better than this one yes but there's
this fascinating thing that let's say we
we did move very close to your idea of a
for Utopia and then one way of looking
at it is
um your happiness is is actually very
relative like it's it's a function of of
what's around you at the time and that
could mean one of two things it could
mean that you start to increase the
resolution of your analysis so um you'll
just zoom in and zoom in and they'll
Always Be Giants to slay because you'll
be focusing in on on smaller and smaller
things or another way of looking at it
is maybe you would see a completely
different Paradigm as as the new
destination
yeah I mean it's that's kind of um
I mean both have a kind of element of
plausibility to me but I think the point
is just very difficult to say isn't it
because we're we're participants in that
process yeah the we that we think the
the me that I think I am right now I
mean even coming to talk to you I was I
wasn't having a crisis of confidence but
I was thinking oh you know he's been
looking at stuff that I wrote five years
ago and do I really think that anymore
and who am I and you know well of course
I'm not the same person that I was five
years ago or will be in five minutes
time and uh all I can do is is kind of
it's kind of a constant process of
course correction I mean I'm here right
now this is what I think would be a good
move when I get to that point who knows
um you know there have been some
constants in I mean it's useful also
when you get a bit older to look back at
some of the
uh theme is let's say you know the sort
of maybe not constants but there's
certain recurring rhythms in there that
everybody
seems to carry with them and and I'm I'm
okay with mine you know and I think they
they are have been a reasonably good
rule of thumb for me in terms of um
findings you know some elements of
happiness in this reality that is the
one that we are experiencing right now
but also feeling that uh particularly in
a shared way that I've experimentally
experimentally experienced I'm not quite
sure that's fits but it's I've seen it
I've experienced it I've understood it
and I know that it could be uh more and
wider and I know that even if it's only
simply because of the very visible
um
uh incredible devotion of resources to
not allowing that to happen if this was
so unnatural why put so much time and
energy and force and violence into
making sure that it doesn't happen well
I mean there are some obvious reasons
due to the which would be the
distribution of resources in the current
world the you know the nature of some
people feeling that they must
be superior to other people in that
division that's been maintained I mean
whatever your explanation for it is I
constantly observe the force with which
those situations are maintained against
something else and is that something
else I'm interested in
uh trying to unlock
okay so um you did a talk on mental
health and Ai and you discussed the
potential benefits and concerns of
applying Ai and machine learning
techniques to Mental Health Care
um specifically through voice analysis
which I thought was quite interesting
highlighting the promise of early
detection and intervention and mental
health but also looking at some of the
potential drawbacks especially with
vulnerable populations that are being
targeted and you're also speaking to
this concept of epistemic Injustice
which I think is particularly
interesting I mean could you could you
introduce that yeah I'll try with due
apologies to Miranda fricker whose work
it was that I read to try to uh because
I think
um I'm mad at if she was the first to
use the term but she certainly wrote
extensively about it and that's where I
borrowed it from
and I think again again that comes out
of the uh out of a sort of broadly
actually feminist philosophy
and it would be a way of understanding
um women's experience I think
particularly women's experiences in that
through that process of trying to uh you
know transform from being voiceless
and she was trying to characterize I
think
what women's experiences uh you know and
we're talking still up until the present
day you know typically can be and so she
she
um actually had a
a couple of levels of this and epistemic
Injustice would be
um
profuse apologies for not being able to
recapitulate her very uh
succinct phrasings of it but it'd be
something like
the devaluing of the speaker would be
the epistemic one in there or the
devaluing of their knowledge of their
own experience so it that's it you know
it's that's simply the kind of thing
where uh somebody's own expression of
their own subjective experience counts
less than
essentially an exterior version of what
uh their experiences mean
so this is the the tyranny of the
algorithm so the the way the algorithms
work is they look at regularities they
look at the head of the distribution and
then you have this long tail where you
have all the entropy gets snipped off is
it because it's it's it's not
represented so you're essentially
talking to the voice of the algorithm
overpowering the the voices
of people with lived experience well the
algorithm is and that's why I borrowed
the term because it seemed to be a neat
fit with my understanding of what's
happening with algorithms or could
happen with a you know
this kind of algorithmic authority uh
but
maybe I can drop in what I think is an
absolutely key point to
um all of the things I'm trying to say
with all of this stuff which is that's
not uh something new that these
algorithmic expression of it or the
manifestation through AI or anything
else is
um a difference and a continuity it's a
difference because of that particular
way these things are done
and uh you know they they happen
differently because of the Technologies
they introduce a different Dynamic and a
different scale
but
they aren't you know that I miss
epistemic Injustice wasn't you know or
underfrica didn't come up with that term
because of algorithms she came up with
it because that's women's ongoing
experience over whatever period of time
you want to think about
um
and it is and this is maybe my thing
that that's going to be intensify
potentially
by uh
you know the rolling up into
this idea of uh algorithmic Authority
deriving from you know it's somehow more
objective and scientific and uh you know
grounded in data and whatever else it is
that's used to attribute to Authority I
mean she had another one about
um
hermeneutic Injustice yes you know so
it's like it's not just the speaker's
word but the speaker's understanding I
mean you could maybe
I've only just thought of this actually
but you could maybe think of that as a
kind of you know she's really sort of uh
she's dissing a sort of philosophical
gaslighting there you know where where
somebody else's version of your uh your
experience of reality is more more valid
than yours and it and I think and I
think that's not an accident I mean
gaslighting is a very gendered it's used
against all of us but it's a very
gendered uh technique
and it's a gender technique that has
been primarily mobilized in in
uh
male dominant gender relations and you
know
again I mean I tried to pick up on both
of those because they seem very relevant
to to machine learning in general AI in
general particularly when it comes into
the social Realm that it will have a
voice
that is listen to more than the voice of
the subject let's say you know you're
interested in subjectivity the subject
here is the subject voice certain
subjects voices will count for far less
than
Technical Systems voice in that and
certain subjects little understanding of
their own experience will count for far
less so it's uh it's not I don't think
there's any particularly restricted to
any domain I mean the
the unfortunate thing for me is to watch
uh
some of my predictions about the way
these things will work actually coming
into practice there was a good
investigation by
um well by a group of people
excuse me Andrea
a group University of Journalism
organization called Lighthouse reports
we're looking into now this would be
machine learning it's not AI so it's I
think it was random forests actually the
particular algorithm but it's a spotting
welfare fraud yes right and it's you
know it was
uh very visceral kind of demonstration
of this because on the on if you like on
the word of the algorithm was taken as
having sort of sufficient weight
that uh people were literally had their
sort of front doors battered down more
or less and you know investigators going
through their laundry and checking the
number of toothbrushes on their in their
bathroom or what have you because the
algorithm had said it may be that
they're actually living with a partner
when they're claiming a single parent
allowance or whatever it is you know
they'd been marked as suspicious now you
know that's pulling together two things
you know very starkly isn't it you know
very abstract mathematical calculations
Based on data and real visceral-lived
experience and and I think that's yeah
yes pretty good example of it well
that's a wonderful example I mean
there's two components to that I mean
first of all even random forests they're
sufficiently complicated as to be
unintelligible right
um just just like a machine learning
algorithm and also it speaks to this
concept of good Hearts law which is when
an objective becomes a measure it
distorts the system and that's because
of a feedback loop yeah so you can
imagine when you start rendering
judgments and then that actually affects
the behavior of the underlying system
you get this very very pernicious and
feedback loop but um the epistemic bit
in particular is interesting because it
it you didn't use the term AI model
epistemic speaks to this kind of
collective knowledge we have which can
then be used to oppress marginalized
communities and that will become
reinforcing and that there was actually
a third form of epistemic Injustice
called testimonial Injustice and this
happens when someone's credibility as a
source of information is is unfairly
dismissed or diminished usually due to
prejudices or stereotypes associated
with their Identity or social group
reinforcing marginalization yeah
absolutely I mean it's funny you should
say that because
when I was thinking about the the
example I just cited that was in
Rotterdam
um of of the random Forest fraud
detection it's also another
maybe in law but
um I won't call it mcclellan's law but a
rule of thumb
would be that uh whatever you think not
you personally but whatever and
practitioners may think they are
designing a system for
um if they are kind of blindly ignoring
um the way our current systems actually
work then those could have what might be
to their creators very unintended and
harmful effects and what I'm trying to
get at there is
uh
suspicion
you know this this side that this
positioning of certain people is always
being suspicious
of being subject to suspicion and that
is really you know a very socially
striated experience you know which
probably we don't experience that much
and other people experience all the time
you know that their word is doubted
because they are after all ever you know
from a housing estate in Tottenham and
it's very clear that's where they're
from you know their word will
immediately
um count for Less when it comes to any
and debate about what's really happened
in a given situation and
that's something that happens it's not
the fault of machine learning but if it
gets embedded in the model and gets
reinforced to the model as you were
describing then I think it yes it was
our shared problem in a sense it is the
fault of machine learning and you can
disentangle the algorithm from the the
way the the data is structured I mean
data scientists they do feature
engineering they do what they call
business analysis and they understand
useful abstractions they transform the
data and you can imagine how once that
schema becomes crystallized it will have
exactly the reinforcing epistemic
Injustice that that you speak to yeah
but it's from a responsibility point of
view it's like the um the the thought
experiment of the Drone operator is it
the Drone is it the operator does it
matter that the operators on the other
side of the world it becomes
sufficiently diffuse that it's quite
difficult to pin down
responsibility and and what should be
done but it's your it's going back to
the the the term that you raised again
which is entanglement is like our
prior ways of thinking about this kind
of thing has been to try to divide up
responsibility in a very particular way
because it was uh it sort of worked
pragmatically even if it wasn't always
um if it could always be questioned to
some extent you know but we well
pragmatically have to do that and also
we constructed legal Frameworks to do
that
um you know that say well under under
this
because any real process is quite
entangled anyway but under this
particular situation we will we will
assign the majority of blame to this
particular actor or maybe to this
particular system you know that's why we
have safety standards or whatever it is
um and the you know the the like it's
like drone operator is like
it's one word isn't it it's the
Inseparable drone and operator system
well actually those systems are actually
a lot larger because the Drone operator
is only one part of a much larger thing
which has
um
hierarchical order giving structures it
has satellite data you know and these
things are very entangled and you know
it sounds to me like maybe I don't know
if you were saying this but that's what
it's making me think of is that part of
the task at the moment is to to
reconceive of responsibility Frameworks
you know in a way that that we can work
with these uh much more intensified uh
or highly fused entanglements you know
it's never really been possible to
separate people from their tools but um
it's certainly impossible with these new
tools and uh if we're going to
understand how to not just hold people
responsible but how to do things
responsibly then we do need to think
about how how to reconceive of those
things but it all it also made me before
I lose it because you mentioned a minute
ago um and you know the interpretation
of humor and jokes and I don't know
whether you had it in mind but in the
I think the paper open AI put out
introducing GPT for you I think one of
the examples they give is it
successfully interpreting interpreting a
joke or was that the one with the VGA
connector plugged into the phone no
that's a oh maybe maybe this is from a
different paper but I'm yeah I might be
getting confused but this is the more
layers one you know more as an moar oh
okay yeah so it's it's I'm not I don't
know if it's XKCD but it could well be
but it's a two panel joke basically
where
um the first one is a data scientist
doing the things you were talking about
of like uh you know going oh you know we
need to think about these parameters and
you know this particular situation we
need to get an expert into this that's
the first panel and the second panel is
just another uh stick figure going
Okay the reason I'm bringing this out is
the punch line here is not just that
it's the punch line that's a okay that's
a funny joke for the people who are in
who are on the inside I think that's
funny you probably think that's okay
it's funny for the Deep learning people
because it's like funny we won kind of
funny as well like like kind of screw
you backward looking data scientist you
know I can just add more layers and data
and and you know look actually I win I I
do deep mind I do open AI I I win
and there's that Hubris in it but the
point of it is it was in the paper and
they allegedly got a GPT to explain the
joke which it it does it explains the
fact that
um
here in the first panel is the
old-fashioned machine learning data
scientist having to do lots of feature
Engineering in order to achieve a
moderate result in here and it explains
the joke
the joke for me in the not really very
funny sense is that
um
it's
that those two panels what the vector
they show is from
I agree with you about the rigidity of
the models and the Tyranny that they may
involve but at least at that stage they
were having to think about the context
they were having to maybe engage a
domain expert at some point I'm not
saying it was ever a very empowering or
that they went as far as to actually get
the users in or anything like as
outrageous as that but they did at least
think about the situation and what I'm
saying there is as a trajectory of
thought increased thoughtlessness
moving you know in the Deep learning
triumphalism is like we don't need that
stuff anymore we don't need to
understand we have generalizable models
that are so successful we just seem to
point our space cannon in the right
direction and we can solve education and
we can solve Healthcare we can solve
cover like that that didn't really work
did it but never mind
um you know
we we are the new Gods striding the
Earth okay I'm having a dig the more
powerful effect is one that is again as
historical I mean I take my reading from
Hannah Arend this idea of
thoughtlessness
and I suspect we'll get around to the
conversation about terms like fascism
but she developed that through attending
the trial of Eichmann and saying how is
it that a
pallid characterless
um
semi-zombie-like character like this and
utter boring bureaucrat could be
responsible for so much evil and she
read through that uh you know this idea
of systems that allow people not to
think in a way and so far there's a
really long-winded way of explaining my
own joke my joke is that that's there's
GPT
identifying the very trajectory which it
itself is encouraging which is one of
increased thoughtlessness and therefore
harm in the world and its own successful
reading of this joke is is just another
ratcheting up of that very idea that
these language models
I don't want to go back to all the
conversation but these language models
are harmful in the world so I just
wanted to add in there that's really
interesting first of all I could pose
that another alternative is the language
model might give you some abstraction
and give you because a lot of
communication is about we have shared
World Knowledge we have shared
abstractions which live in our language
yeah and
um there's a there's a kind of
compression when we communicate and part
of what we're doing is is I know what
you know I have a theory of mind I
communicate to you yes and in a way I'm
I'm trying to be sufficiently
representative but also reducing the
amount of cognitive work that you need
to do yeah and so if the model did
provide a more of an abstract answer
which could actually counterpose this
relational view that you're just
speaking to well this is funny from the
point of view of this person yeah but
that's not the magic of language models
that they give you a very concrete
example example which actually makes you
lazy and it and it truncates your frame
of reference your space of cognition
um
you know which I I agree with what
Chomsky said recently it it's You could
argue it both ways you could argue that
it makes you lazy it makes you a zombie
the zombification of society or you
could argue that like Sat Nav did it
actually kind of opened you up gives you
more time like the emancipation of women
for example after
um you know like the pill and washing
machines and so on that there's a form
of emancip emancipation
um but um but another interesting point
though just to push back a tiny bit Yeah
is You could argue we've just said
epistemic Injustice models
isn't language a model right so
already the terms that we use them and
we've we've done this language game
we've converged we've materialized on
common understandings and I know in
post-modernism language is very
important yeah yeah so even forgetting
about AI for a minute like isn't
language extremely oppressive
can be for sure yeah
I mean
I guess the sense I get from from your
the situation you're posing is simply
that
um
it's not that
what the machines are doing again is
something so radically different it's
that if we want to
have uh and share and and sort of
maybe debate or even contest models of
the world and I don't really I'm not
motivated to go through a machine to do
that I'm not motivated to
to pile all of human
discourse into that mathematical
large mathematical transformation
function with all of the additional
um
limitations that that brings in order to
bring it back out
for my understanding I'd rather just
talk to you
or talk to other people who have some
other kind of problem or get people
together to discuss their shared
problems
because in the process of having to do
it through the machine
it might sometimes be kind of
entertaining actually you know
um I'm a bit sort of
I don't know what it is I mean because I
think about these things too much I see
GPT 3 or GPT I haven't seen much out of
gp4 myself yet
I'm like the amazement for me has gone
in about half a second I'm like yeah
okay I'm kind of so what do you know I
just don't care uh because it's still
just a music box it's still just a trick
a mathematical operation that emulates
something that I care about no it's not
something that I care about and uh
where am I going to do this yeah the
point being that
that diversion itself comes with
the ghost labor that we talked about you
know the sort of marginalized labor it
comes with
a ridiculous
allocation of resources
money and time and people people's
thought or that thought could be
thinking something else
and let's not even go into the carbon
emissions you know this is this is a
an insane machine to build
why would I build this insane machine in
terms of its uh
resource capture
never never mind its attempts at
hegemony in order to say well I could
use it to reflect back on
things that other people have said
thanks there are better ways to do that
oh they'll stick around don't worry
about now no my God you're telling me I
can expect some angry emails
it's funny you know like uh like
becoming a bit more well-known or
whatever that is I'm getting some weird
on social media now which I was
never had you know because I was always
in my little but not my bubble but my
little intersectional bubble
you know and I just never had that
internet and let's get people that
popping on my timeline going well you
know just whatever really I'm I'm
finally tired of what you're saying is
like
hey I didn't even know you were
listening and B I don't give a yeah
don't read the comments on YouTube right
right yeah yeah you really are you're in
that space
um well to be honest I I've done very
well but um
the space that you're in does does
invite does invite some nasty comments
I'm okay with it
um okay
so in in the last chapter of your book
the anti-fascist AI uh you argued for
for this approach to AI which goes
beyond immediate resistance to
algorithmic violence and fascistic
solutionism instead aiming to shift the
focus from resisting AI to restructuring
the conditions that give rise to AI in
the first place which we spoke to yeah
so you said that such an approach must
be decolonial and feminist as AI is both
Colonial in its intellectual framework
and racialized properties of exteriation
and exclusion
as well as enabling gender-based
violence and promoting violently
patriarchal systems so you advocated for
the construction of an apparatus that
supports the common good based on the
principles such as Democratic
self-governance and also commitment to
transformative system change and
horizontal cooperation
so um yeah you you said an anti-fascist
approach to AI is one that is prepared
to no platform any sign of fascistic
solutionism or its normalization and
maybe I should just quickly ask about
the language a little bit because when I
when I first read this
um some of the language seemed slightly
kind of charged to me and I'm I'm an
outside an outsider to this to me so um
some language such as anti-fascist
decolonial feminist
um you know and and the the association
with violence stood out in particular so
I just wondered if you could elaborate
on the motivations behind your choice of
language it's historical and
intellectual Origins and how you believe
employing such such language contributes
or enhances your work in addressing the
ethics project
yeah yeah well I hope it's um I hope
it's more than slightly charged you know
I hope it's very charged yes I was being
I think yeah being very yeah polite
you're a very polite host well thank you
yes
um
so it's meant to be very charged um and
it's not meant to be
um it's not trying to be in people's
faces for the sake of it but maybe the
common one common strand we could start
with there is
um as you mentioned there's other things
decolonial them is so forth I think
maybe or and also something you referred
to a minute ago about
um let's say the term administrative
violence I think you're right you know
there's there's a strand of concern in
my thinking that doesn't stray too far
from concerns about violence and that's
because I
you know I do see uh systemic violence
at all levels in the Here and Now uh I
mean I will say Universal Credit you
know Universal Credit seems to me like a
violent system in the sense that and and
I am pretty sure it's deliberately
designed this way
um that
you know giving as it does people very
explicitly the absolute minimum to live
on and then arranging a series of
potentially sanctionable uh events which
are very hard to completely avoid
especially if your life is kind of
complicated and difficult and uh
restricted
uh to the so that you get sanctioned to
only 70 of what the benefit itself
establishes is its own minimal level of
livability is violent you're removing
from people in a relatively arbitrary
way that simple means of existence and I
think we can see these kind of violences
all around us right now the idea that
shells should be taking over Howard and
many billions it was in profit at the
same time that
you know people are having to choose
between feeding their kids or heating
their homes this is violent to me these
are not violence is not just uh
a blow you know it's not just a a
directed physical attack of one person
or another it's it's uh to me you know
things that uh violently render asunder
people's capacity to
um live at what we would consider bare
minimum conditions of
um existence and uh
um lack of suffering
and so
in all of the things that you know you
you name check there there are kinds of
violences you know I think most people
would understand that colonialism was
kind of at least established by violence
but then
there are other kinds there are other
kinds of violence that
um
well still you know we we've said in
colonialism never really went away but
there are many kinds of violence there
going back to the kind of uh
violent injustices of epistemic and
testimonial and hermeneutic you know
that the
colonialized people's own sense of
themselves was
violently transformed so so
I see like a sound like somebody who
sees violence everywhere but I think
it's important to recognize violent
elements in all of these relations
because actually a lot of the time they
are really just violent you know that we
could could I um frame it a little bit
so as you said when when I place a gun
to someone's head that's
clearly violence it's about
intelligibility yeah and I think you're
speaking to a form of exasperation when
as as things as the scale
um you know increases
um especially over time and space right
things diffuse right and are moral
intuitions become faulty yeah so what
you're doing is you're saying okay well
I'm zooming out a little bit I'm drawing
a boundary around this yeah and it's a
little bit like if I poison a well for
50 years people might slowly die of
cancer and so on and you're saying
that's violence yeah but most people
don't see it that way so I'm going to
use charge language to help you
understand
I think that's a fair
uh you know that that's a fair
characterization of it I mean I think
it's interesting you know it relates to
our earlier discussions about
entanglement I mean these this is also
addressing entanglements
um it's also addressing the thing I was
saying a minute ago about
thoughtlessness to me thoughtlessness is
because on the other hand I really don't
think that a lot of the time these
things are that distant
you know it's not hard
for
okay somebody working in it let's let's
I'm just going to stick with the
benefits thing because it's right at the
front of my mind okay we already know
that the worker who sanctions that
person is aware of what they're doing
they can see the immediate impacts they
are driven by many things they only need
to keep a job
um the fact that they may get as as it
turns out a benefit you know a bonus for
sanctions that's maybe we could all
understand that that's directly
complicit in some way but then there's
the manager you were talking about the
power of metrics earlier on there's the
manager sitting in the back office there
who has to fulfill uh he has to fill a
spreadsheet has to fulfill it you know
get get the right readings on a
dashboard whatever it is that they're
being assessed by they have some sense
of what they're doing of course it is
somewhat insulated but I don't think
it's to me it's it's not so insulated I
think we've been trained
to not see these things I don't think
it's that I'm trying to do something or
but by doing what you characterize is
not uh it's not an elaborate operation
you know it's
really that most of the time we've been
taught not to look
yeah so it's similar to that thought
experiment where a fisherman
um catches fish and and the the
coarseness of the net means that some
fish go through the net and we just
don't we don't see those fish because
they don't get caught by the net so
you're saying there's a fundamental
structure there which affects our
default ability to recognize things yeah
and I think that's a highly conditioned
one and a highly you know it's not
somebody sat down in the back room to
design it it's an emergent property of a
system that relies on that
uh width of hole in the net in order to
sustain itself you know it's
self-reinforcing so that we're looking
at that's again maybe why thinking about
Technical Systems is also
a useful
tool more broadly because you know we're
thinking about feedback loops but
actually feedback loops are everywhere
and reinforcements and layerings
and recursiveness I mean all these
things already happening in these
systems and and and they do produces
violence so yeah I mean I'm using
language about
um violence is also maybe just because
um
yeah another consequence of the apparent
abstraction of Technical Systems they're
apparent complexity their apparent
removal from the Realms of everyday life
um
and actually the real
physical and semantic removal of the
people producing those systems you know
it will exist a lot of the time I mean
you know Europe's
or whatever you want to say is a is a
long way from Tottenham okay
in one sense you know people are
inhabiting it or have a habitus it's
very very different and that is not
accidental that's constructed to be that
way
um you know as a mandarin wandering the
halls of Whitehall
um you know is is constructed to be
making decisions at a sufficient
distance
from the possible consequences because
otherwise it will actually be very
difficult to do those things
um and I'm saying
let's make it difficult let's make it
difficult to do those things without
understanding the consequences for
people's lived experiences which I would
describe as as forms of violence so at
the very least leaving aside the
fascistic thing which we can talk about
but just the violent uh violence maybe
in the language I don't know the
bringing in
to focus the violences yet that's quite
um
quite deliberate because there's a few
things that I mean first of all as we
said language is a model just like a
machine learning algorithm so I can
understand why
an attempt to reframe the language for
example the term fascism or even racism
as well I think is another another good
example but you you could push back on
that and say to what extent does it um
dilute or trivialize the word and and
also because now you what what you've
essentially done is is abstracted the
term and that abstraction makes certain
assumptions and extrapolations which
might have uh you know might be slightly
opinionated but on on the dilution thing
and we'll leave racism to one side but
maybe fascism is a better example I mean
would you would you
do you think it dilutes the notion I
mean most people would say Vladimir
Putin is a fascist at this point some
people even Donald Trump and do you
think in any way this overloading of the
term kind of dilutes that meaning yeah
no okay
uh well okay I'm just being clip
I think
I think no okay I think it's important
to be quite precise about what fascism
is I may or may not have done that job
in the book I tried
um because I think
fascism
isn't isn't neatly separable that's the
point but it is particular
I don't think we're we you and I are not
living in fascism at the moment
um
and if it comes to that we'll know it
it's a very particular
political and social formation
um
I think we can see fascistic activity
around us right now I think you'd have
to be blind in the UK of 2023 not to see
uh
the rise of
fascist intervention in social conflict
the crowds uh you know fighting to get
into hotels into the hotel in where
Asylum Seekers are being housed
it's it's real but it's not the dominant
system in our society thankfully I think
it's pretty close in some others
um
so my my purpose of talking about
fascism is
multiple in one way I am saying that Yes
actually really existing historically
definable fascism is actually a problem
right now it's
more powerful and more widely
um adopted than uh probably ever has
been in my lifetime
um
then there are reasons for that because
if you study the historical actuality of
fascism
it tends to emerge as a solution to
crises
crises usually of the hegemonic dominant
whatever system I think
you know so so there are these reasons
right there were reasons why
I mean they're always fascists they're
always a small number of people who
through their own
um
their own damaged character choose to
believe in these things most of the time
like any other
extremist and and distorted belief
system it's it's always there but it's
marginal because most people are
basically thankfully despite our
experiences relatively filled with
common sense and and sort of a
reasonable amount of respect for each
other I do believe that's the dominant
Force most of the time
but um would you agree that that this
argument that it's a form of abstract
fascism in in the sense that before the
term connoted physical violence and now
we're in the infosphere and oppression
is different and just like in the
infosphere there's increasingly less
friction with the legal landscape it's
very difficult laws don't work anymore
with these tech companies and similarly
with with oppression
it's becoming far more abstract and
unintelligible
so it's almost like we we need to re
change the meaning of the word to help
people recognize what it is
okay I think I'm starting to get what
where you're coming from
um and I think you know you're trying to
give a sort of
the way I'm interpreting it is you're
trying to give some validity to my use
of the term as being a sort of uh trying
to Forefront some important aspects of
their situation that has become more
diffusion and abstracted and and trying
to bring certain consequences into into
Focus
thanks
it's not what what I think I'm doing
okay cool yeah uh you know because what
I think I'm doing is is trying to do a
couple of things one is I'm saying no no
really no actual fascism Real Fashion
historical fascism
it's um
we should be forefronting a concern for
fascism
in this Society in our world right now
we have a fascist prime minister in
Italy not not somebody who is pretty
fascist of it explicitly that is a
fascist party was a fascist party since
it was founded in the early 1950s
you know it was it was a promiscellini
party it's a fascist party and she's a
prime minister in Italy we have
fascistic governments in Hungary in
religious
fascism in Poland these are not abstract
distant possibilities and this is one of
the things about fascism is that nobody
really believes it until it happens it's
one of its successes right that we wake
up one day
and we have the system and then it's too
late
that's when sorry could you just um for
the for the benefit of the audience
because you started to Define it and
then and then I think you moved on but
you said it's about responding to crises
and so on because I think with a
definition that would get away from any
notion of abstract fascism sure
well I think yeah I mean the reason why
it's quite even different to far-right
politics and I mean you know we we have
a kind of um
well you and I although you know
slightly different sort of uh
Generations still inherited an idea of
left and right which I think itself is
pretty fragmented now actually not that
helpful most of us got an idea what the
far right means the fascism is not the
far right only it's it's kind of beyond
the far right so what is a fascistic uh
let's say regime is actually a
revolutionary one in some way you know
it's not simply a takeover of this
existing regime it's one that
mobilizes a takeover of the existing
regime but you know with this ideology
of the necessity
of radical transformation of the
untenability of the existing status quo
or
um the existing um
uh falling apart of the status quo right
so it's it's transformative
it it it
requires a new being you know that that
people themselves are transformed and it
requires a
it establishes a Unity
but it establishes a Unity which is of
of course like absolutely exclusionary
it establishes a unity in opposition to
you know there's always another with
fascism and that other is is the great
threat to to our existence
yes so it describes a um chaotic
transient
consolidation of power yes a violent
transformation of power through an
ideology of
um of transcendence of transcending the
the current situation to a new
purified
uh
a new purified world
that at the same time is a return to a
lost world so you you know there's this
always uh very visible in in fascistic
um
narratives you know is the idea that
there was a better time
right but I think that part might be
missing from the AI because I don't I'm
not hearing the message that we want to
go back to a previous good World it
seems quite utopian in the sense of
there is a an exciting New World well
I'm not saying that AI is fascist right
um because fascism is a political
category
and what I'm trying to explore is is
this okay this idea of a technopolitics
so I am saying that certain of the
affordances of AI or some of it's very
concrete and seemingly to me
irretrievable characteristics are
potentially fascistic
and and that maybe that's the other side
of things really is the
this is again what I'm trying to hit
with this is
the difference between
um
some
concerned views of AI which is about
bias and discrimination
and that's where often the ethics comes
into it that you you referring to you
know that we're going to have a
situation that sort of um
really unfairly tips to balance
you know and we're what I'm trying to
allude to is that
um well first off that banners doesn't
exist you know it's not starting for a
Level Playing Field
um but not only are we not starting from
a Level Playing Field that there is
within the highly unequal and asymmetric
and I would say violent
aspects of society that we currently
inhabit
are the makings of that future fascism
in one way or another and there are
there are trackable tendencies that
enhance that possibility
othering
clearly that would be one
um essentializing
uh you know
ordering things in terms of us and them
and in and out
and these are all they're not uh fascism
but they're kind of aspects that uh
are used to to substantiate and
reinforce and develop fascism if it
arises and that's why I think we have to
be very very concerned because actually
the you you know if I think what's
picking up on something you said you
know that
you're kind of I think alluding to the
idea which is
um reasonably well discussed that the
systems escape the law in some way right
that's yes but I'm saying that isn't the
problem yes right I'm saying that the
law already doesn't restrain
the things we should be worried about
that the law already in fact validates
some of the things that we should be
worried about that the law what these uh
intensified effects are showing is not
that the things are escaping the law
they're showing exactly why the law
itself is not the solution I mean
something that historically uh people
sort of is often is misrepresented is
this sense of uh for example Nazi
Germany as a dictatorship
it was a legal structure
it was it was always legally enabled
legally enacted okay the forms of law
that were introduced to enact a Nazi
regime and extend it and deepen it you
know leading up to the war
um you know were largely based on
creating
as a gamban said zones of exception you
know areas in which other in which
protections of the law did not apply to
certain groups of people
but that was done legally
on on them in I spoke to really about
this and he said part of the problem is
the the pace and scale it's
unprecedented and you could also argue
that there is just a fundamental
mismatch between the needs of
Corporations and society and so on yeah
but um what what folks like floridi say
is that we need to have strong
institutions and institutions that can
keep up with the pace of change of
technology and so that we can change the
legal
um interface to reduce the brittleness
with the technology landscape so there's
there's this idea that if only we could
keep pace and have the correct
governance and and legislation then it
wouldn't be a problem
right right would you push back on that
oh great I get to do some pushing back
yeah please
no you've been so kind of you you've
been so sort of um gentle with your
pushy back I can't mainly say oh push
back harder it's okay
um yeah I would push back on that
definitely I think
um
you know I I agree that of course one of
the challenges of the transformative
Technologies is pace and scale
particularly scale actually
um
but you know but my my um you know my
warning light would be not only that but
that in context uh I picked up a phrase
a couple of months ago polycrisis have
you heard that one it's like um Omni
shambles yeah yeah okay it is exactly
it's just it's just a push away of
saying omnisembles I mean but or at
least it's kind of identifying a number
of very specific crises right we've got
the climate crisis perhaps overarching
everything
um we've got I mean we're speaking now
you know in mid-march when we've just
maybe apparently dodged another
Financial collapse maybe Silicon Valley
Bank look at it but it also somehow
circulates back to Silicon Valley right
um you know we don't know yet if we
successfully avoided that but maybe it
seems like we did you know so anyway
we've got austerity still ongoing right
we've got the financial collapse we've
got
um war in Europe
right so we've got many overlapping
cries of the polycars of the omnisone
you know
um and I'm just saying that alongside
what you were just saying because
um it's not just perhaps urgent to
caution about how we're reducing
radically transformative Technologies at
a pace that we find difficult to
conceive of
okay and we're doing it in a situation
where pretty much everything is falling
apart at a rate that we also seemingly
find difficult to conceive of because we
definitely not got a handle on it
and the particular way I'd pushed back
against the institutional thing is
because institutions are entirely
complicit in that
well similarly with um Silicon Valley
Bank in the UK you know how it works
um a lot of it is about perceptions and
the market and confidence sure and uh
soon our prime minister he very quickly
um became the guarantor for the um
companies in the UK who had received
investment yeah that's a great example
of you would say that the failure of
government and institutions because the
the prevailing Paradigm with markets and
corporations and and private Enterprise
that is too big to fail and it has to
come first yeah it has to come
you I think you nailed it it has to come
first before I don't know the kids who
don't get School meals yes why does that
have to come first why I say well I mean
I understand that like Financial
collapse is not going to be good for any
of us but but yeah you nailed it
but I think it's not
I'm not imagining sort of a world
without institutions per se you know or
rather let's say I'm not I'm certainly
not promoting in a world without
organization
but I think the thing that keeps those
things on track as much as they ever are
is is other forces you know it's
um
to some extent
whether we'll put up with it
you know we we do and and certainly in
the UK I mean we seem to be putting up
with a hell of a lot you know I I
honestly expected
um there to be well to be honest much
more civil unrest by this stage given
the kind of suffering that people are
experiencing
but that's another form of abstraction
which is to say we say we need
institutions because we need expertise
and I think the the dmos have accepted
this notion to a certain extent maybe
more skeptical after covid but this
notion that
these things are unintelligible to a
certain extent and we need to have
powerful institutions who understand
this stuff who can make decisions on on
our behalf so there are many layers of
misdirection and abstraction between the
the voting public and and how Powers is
yielded I'd I
um I I don't buy it right uh well how
could it be different yeah yeah exactly
that's that's the interesting question
for me
um
I don't buy it because and and I'm
trying to move to the how it could be
different I don't buy it because
um
there's an element of of quite extreme
reductionism in there you know that that
um things are unintelligible I I agree
with you know things are sort of
fundamentally unintelligible but that
doesn't mean we can't get a handle on
them you know to a pre in a pragmatic
way
and it's how we do that and if we invest
all that you know let's let's click
let's keep it grounded in the thing that
we sort of came together to talk about
the algorithmic systems or the AI says
because they are definitely being looked
to as things that have sufficient scale
uh you know capacity to to to I I
honestly think actually that the people
who are used to that way of thinking
that you know we need to have a few
experts in the middle holding this ship
together because otherwise our wheels
are really going to come off look at the
jittering the things already you know we
need it you need we're only us are
holding it together with a Thin Blue
Line at the middle here we're holding it
together and and actually that's not
working what have we got in our toolbox
AI
AI is going to help save the day right
and anyway I don't really buy that
original model in the first place I do
think that if um actually a more stable
system is going to emerge it will be
much more plural and I think maybe this
is something we could probably from
things that you've said to me already
before that we we might find some sort
of common ground on there that pluralism
actually is really really important and
that
um actually it already exists if you
look if you sort of start to to do that
zoning in you're talking about a society
you'll find that at every level of
society I mean our Park the little one
where I go and walk the dog only exists
because there is a sufficient sort of
strength in the local park users group
you know to First maintain it as a
semi-hygienic environment and also to
push back against those different forces
whether it's the council or the school
next door or whoever it is you know who
would for one of their own reasons
perhaps want to to to rather that wasn't
there this is this kind of balance of
forces to this dynamic balance you know
this pluralism is necessary and from my
opinion the expertise that I most value
is the ones most closest to the thing
it's not that I'm devaluing philosophers
or technologists or um
Medics you know or any other uh highly
distilled form of expertise in its place
you know as part of that but that's the
primary expertise yes yes but um you can
view this at multiple scales yes so
you're talking about self-organization
at successive scales yes and the type of
self-organization you're speaking to
works very well at the scale where it is
manageable rare and intelligible it's
similar thing with with the covid
rollout so the government have folks who
are managing the you know how they do
the the vaccinations yeah in various
different parts and it's an
organizational Nightmare and it requires
a certain skill set and to be honest
they didn't do a very good job of it
anyway yeah but you you can see how when
when you when you scale this up to the
the nation level it becomes very very
difficult yeah well
uh uh yeah sorry I'm only thinking I
don't really consider the nation to be
particularly important uh my apologies
no no yes no borders no boys no borders
but anyway okay there has to be some
coordination at different scale
definitely and I mean that's what I'm
interested in you know I don't know if
you're if you know a book what's it
called actually uh is Andrew Pickering
book on on sort of lost cybernetics oh
yeah you mentioned that on your YouTube
video right yeah you know the sort of
Stafford beer style simonetics and you
know
which they in turn sort of modeled on
you know allegedly modeled on biological
organisms but anyway I don't know I
don't really care it does seem to have
some value in the sense that uh actually
it's sort of building on recursiveness
to some extent you know it's it's
um it's not saying that uh the local is
um somewhere above all and sacrosanct
and has no relation to the wider
situation because of course it does
um none of us could survive Town and
Country you know Town and Country didn't
have something to do with each other
um but but it's it's trying to build a
situation that you know in your in USA
you know early on but it's kind of
bottom up
um but it's layering on
um
dimensions of coordination sort of at
their appropriate level that that need
to come into play so that one works
inside the other that there's kind of a
local autonomy but that autonomy is also
at a level when things that might be
decided at a local level also have an
impact you know let's say on the park in
the neighboring Borough then there has
to be a sort of parks coordination level
and so on and so forth and you know um
well the the you know while the
construction of of this of um what's it
called temporary the name of Stafford
beers model but the construction of the
various ways of of cyberneticizing those
systems are are kind of a little bit
fiddly and complicated they seem like a
good start
of consuming of pragmatic ways of
organization that acknowledge the vital
role of
um local expertise
um and then the vital role of the next
layer and then the vital role of the
next layer without elevating any one of
those
into being the one in charge it's saying
that actually in reality none of these
things is in charge and I'm sure if you
are to actually get Rishi sunak in a
quiet moment he'd say I don't really
feel like I'm in charge either you know
I'm buffeted by World forces you know I
have my in the right wing of my party
trying to stab me in the back it's like
it's funny isn't it it turns out that
actually very few uh scenarios turn out
to be really in charge well that's a
very interesting conversation because
power is actually
um
the way we perceive it and the way it is
are two very different things so we
perceive sunac as having a lot of power
right right and when you're actually in
sunax shoes right he'll tell you he
doesn't actually have any power but but
then there's this notion of him exactly
but then there's this notion of as you
say I spoke with Carl friston actually
um a couple of weeks ago he's a famous
neuroscientist and and he has this
notion of um collective intelligence
which uses his free energy principle and
you can you can apply this everywhere
even in a human you can model what he
does is it's called active inference so
you have all of these cybernetic Loops
just like you're speaking about and then
you have um kind of self-organization
and emergence on successive scales and
Consciousness according to him actually
emerges at the top of the hierarchy when
there's a certain counterfactual depth
of planning into the future but but the
the analogy there is is that there's a
concentration of information processing
and and in the Society there's a
concentration of power right when you
have all of these different cybernetic
Loops applied at different scales so to
what extent is that just a natural
phenomenon
the concentration the concentration of
power yeah well you know I mean my my
sort of counter Factor would be if it's
so flipping natural
why is so much effort put all the time
into repressing any other possibilities
because they are you know the the very
start of our educational system is
designed to encourage us to believe that
only obedience to the teachers in the
Headmaster and the school rules are are
acceptable means of being and there are
experiments with I mean I know that the
term free school has taken on a whole
other meaning in the last decade or two
but actually there was a thing called
the free schools where for example I
mean they were only social experiments
I'm not trying to scale them or sort of
even valorize them all I'm saying is
that there are other there are other
ways of doing things and there have been
experiments with other ways of doing
things where um you know I mean
shockingly students would have to get
together in their own general assembly
and decide what their curriculum of the
week was going to be and the amazing
thing about that is obviously being
experimental school it was sort of most
immediately reachable by people who had
kids that were really not fitting in
until a lot of the time into those kind
of more audit systems that you know when
the kids had for themselves decided Well
they really stuck to it you know because
they decided that for themselves and and
I think um
the possibility of these other
possibilities is constantly being
eliminated and I would you know I I I
can't even start to conceive of How It's
plausible this is the only natural
outcome when it's clearly so many
unnatural processes going in to sustain
it and the same thing for example
something that I think we may have
discussed offline I'm not sure but
um at another point is a Lucas plan you
know the idea that
um of the you know the Lucas Arms
Company in the 1970s very similar time
weirdly you know we're back in the in
this massive recession and they were
working in an Arms Company and that was
going to restructure the horrible term
that we're also familiar with you know
that was going to restructure and so
probably a lot of them are going to be
put out of work or things are going to
get a lot tougher but anyway that was
also the same time as echoing back to
our other stuff beginning as the
feminist movement beginnings of the
environmental movement these are all
pervaded these workers own self
discovery where they they set themselves
the task of okay if we're going to do if
we're going to transform this company to
be sustainable survivable
what are we going to do and they
generated their own ideas okay for
actual products but also for how the
production of those products should be
organized it was a you know pretty
impressive I have actually looked at the
Lucas plane as a pretty impressive
comprehensive alternative definition of
how a company could be run and I mean
what do I know but it looked pretty
viable to me but it was com and it
stands as an example of potential but it
was completely repressed and you know
removed as or taken off the board as a
possibility so so I'm sorry to I don't
want to ramble on it but when I push
back to that Assumption of
naturalization is that I don't see
anything natural
in the assertion in the singularity of
what we currently have yes and all
natural is another Observer relative
property and as you say the the lack of
imagination is kind of truncated by the
the Paradigm that we exist in yeah and
and Chomsky spoke to this in in
corporations when you have subversive
elements it's not like there's a bunch
of people smoking a cigar you know
planning out to take over the world it's
a systemic reaction it's like a an
immune response subversive elements are
are eliminated but in a very diffuse and
Abstract way so it's very difficult to
um find a locus of agency you know
directing directing that exclusion right
and also in the globalized world
um it's very difficult when you get
these small elements of
self-organization that you're speaking
to you're in the context of of a much
bigger Paradigm which will have that
immune reaction yeah yeah I know I I 100
agree I don't even know whether many
many years ago I must have picked that
maybe pick that up off chance give
myself because I've always thought about
it as far as I can remember in terms of
this kind of immune response I think
partly because I feel I might have
experienced that a few times myself
anyway but and again it is like you say
it's a sort of diffuse thing
um but still very powerful and uh you
know that's a point of like you say
about sort of naturalization if you step
back and say well there's another kind
of natural process happening here which
is this this sort of elimination of of
rivalries of alternatives
in any case I think
look at
be very hard to argue for
well I think given the obvious uh uh
life-threatening
array of things happening right now on
one level or another it would be
difficult to argue that something else
isn't worth a try
probably many other different things you
know we should we should experiment
multiply
and perhaps and that's my hope for
Technologies you know if there is one
that perhaps there are
aspects of these computational
Frameworks which have kind of lurked in
and out of our conversation that
have something to offer there you know
have something to offer in terms of
communication and scale of a different
kind of you know of recursive and
layered interactive adaptive scale you
know but perhaps there is something to
offer there to these alternative
experiments but it's the values of those
alternative experiments to me that are
most important thing in the technology
if it is useful it's great if it isn't
um I'm not going to cry about it I'm
more interested in those uh real these
alternative realities at least having a
chance to come into being amazing Dr Dan
McQuillen thank you very much for
joining us today it's been an absolute
pleasure thanks for having me
wonderful wonderful amazing um this is
really good we haven't